huot
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
que le regard de l'artiste a changé
entre cet enfant iconique peint sous les
traits de jésus par jean fouquet
et cet enfant couvert de toute la
tendresse de sa mère peint par elisabeth
vigée lebrun
entre le regard triste de cette jeune
fille contraint de vendre ses charmes
dans les rues de londres et
l'insouciance de cet enfant à qui le
suisse félix vallotton donne la liberté
de ne même pas regardé le peintre
de l'allemand dürer aux flamands
revendiquent de l'espagnol velasquez au
moderne renoir miro et picasso à travers
toute l'europe du moyen âge au 20e
siècle les grands maîtres de la peinture
n'ont cessé de représenter les enfants
selon les canons de leur époque
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur rt
france pour deux heures d'émission nous
décryptons comme chaque lundi et
jusqu'au jeudi l'essentiel de
l'information avec nos invités en
plateau et nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite les titres de ce lundi 3
février 2020
le divorce entre le royaume uni et
l'union européenne est acté reste
maintenant à définir la nature de
l'accord qui va régir les relations
commerciales entre londres et bruxelles
et chacun entend défendre ses intérêts à
michel barnier négociateur européen pour
le bric site affirme ne vouloir offrir à
londres un accord commercial très
ambitieux boris johnson oui s'engage à
ne pas faire de concurrence déloyale à
l'union européenne
[Musique]
emmanuel macron salue un tournant avec
varsovie en visite en pologne le chef de
l'état veut apaiser des relations
tendues après le départ du royaume uni
de l'union européenne et le président
français l'a rappelé il souhaite rendre
le projet européen plus fort il s'est
également félicité de la signature d'un
programme de coopération pollono
françaises dans le cadre de leur
partenariat stratégique en france à la
réforme des retraites continue a
cristallisé les débats les députés ont
commencé à examiner en commission
spéciale le texte de loi
l'occasion pour le collectif sos
retraite d'appeler à se mobiliser
plusieurs milliers de manifestants
avocat infirmiers kinés ou encore
stewards son défilé à paris il dénonce l
injustice de ce projet pour les
professions libérales
[Musique]
caucus de l'iowa aujourd'hui une
élection qui marque le coup d'envoi des
primaires démocrates ils sont onze en
lice pour représenter le parti démocrate
à la présidentielle américaine et 4
semble se détacher dans les sondages
nationaux parmi eux joe biden et bernie
sanders
[Musique]
trois jours après le break site le plus
dur reste à faire dès aujourd'hui le
royaume-uni et bruxelles se lance dans
une bataille et elle s'annonce difficile
pour bâtir une nouvelle relation
économique
à quoi vont donc ressembler les nouveaux
accords commerciaux entre les deux
éléments de réponse avec clément
hospital le divorce est actée et c'est
désormais le temps des négociations il
n'y aurait peine et le royaume uni
doivent dès à présent définir les termes
du break site et boris johnson se montre
ferme pour un accord de libre-échange
nul besoin d'accepter les régulations
européennes
le premier ministre britannique veut
tout de même se montrer rassurant et
s'engage à ne pas faire de concurrence
déloyale a lieu nous ne nous engagerons
pas dans une course effrénée vers le bas
nous ne quittons pas l'union européenne
pour saper les normes européennes
nous ne ferons aucune concurrence
déloyale qu'elles soient commerciales
économiques environnementales
il n'écoutait pas seulement ce que nous
disons regardez ce que nous faisons oui
deux quarts de son côté bruxelles a
mises en garde de londres contre toute
tentation de concurrence la présidente
de la commission européenne
ursula von der leyen se dit prête à
négocier un partenariat sans précédent
avec le royaume uni à condition que le
pays respecte les règles durant la
période de négociation qui s'est ouverte
au moment du bric site de notre côté pas
de surprise nous sommes cohérents il y a
des offres pour différents modèles plus
le royaume uni veut être proche plus
l'accès au marché unique sera facile
mais rien n'est gratuit l'accès à ce
marché unique a une grande valeur
c'est le plus grand marché unique au
monde c'est très important et donc je
pense que c'est simplement une question
d'équité que de respecter les règles un
partenariat essentiel pour les européens
cet accord visera notamment à éviter des
droits de douane et où quotas sur les
biens échangés avec le continent
michel barnier le négociateur en chef de
l'union européenne se dit ainsi prêt à
proposer à londres
un accord commercial prison 10 yeux du
jamais vu dans l'histoire de l'union
comme le prévoit la déclaration
politique
nous devons trouver un équilibre entre
les droits et les obligations
c'est ce qu'a rappelé il ya quelques
instants ursula von der leyen ainsi
qu'un équilibre par rapport aux accords
que nous avons avec d'autres pays tiers
je pense ici en particulier aux pays qui
ne sont pas membres de l'union fait
qu'ils sont dans l'espace schengen et
qui acceptent la libre circulation des
personnes et qui construit avec nous
depuis des années cet espace unique de
sécurité
les deux parties ont onze mois pour
négocier le commerce la sécurité la
pêche sont les trois sujets prioritaires
sur la table londres et bruxelles
veulent même s'entendre avant le 1er
juillet prochain sur la pêche
l'un des secteurs où les 27 sont en
position de faiblesse par rapport au
royaume uni les navires européens tech
aujourd'hui chaque année dans les eaux
britanniques pour une valeur de plus de
700 millions d'euros contre 154 millions
d'euros pour les prises des pêcheurs
britannique dont les européennes et pour
en parler nous sommes avec christopher
chanterai vice président de
l'association british community
committee aux france
christopher chanterai bonsoir merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation en
direct sur arte france alors boris
johnson a prononcé son premier discours
depuis la sortie du royaume uni il a
soigneusement évité le mot briques site
qu'est ce que cela révèle fait partie de
la politique là sa politique c'est le
brésil
là le public britannique doit comprendre
que le bric site c'est c'était un sujet
pas ses bonnes entrées dans une nouvelle
ère c'est fait donc on entre en quelques
heures en quelque sorte il a raison on
va négocier là
les rapports futurs donc la sortie est
fait on n'en parle plus dans les
rapports futurs justement la volonté de
boris johnson c'est de revenir un
champion du libre-échange reprendre le
contrôle de sa politique commerciale
est ce qu'il pourra effectivement selon
vous re négocier tout azimuts comme il
le souhaite
je pense qu'il pourra négocier en
parallèle avec différents pays mais est
ce que savait ce que le résultat sera
une réussite pour le paie pour le pays
nous nous qui représentons les citoyens
britanniques en france et dans un sens
plus large bout des seniors qui est une
autre association qui représente les
intérêts des britanniques établis dans
les pays de l'union à 27 nous espérons
pouvoir influencer ces négociations pour
que les droits qu'on a perdue avec
l'accord du 31 janvier soit rétabli donc
certains droits qu on a perdu parce que
quel droit très concrètement il ya
notamment tout ce qui concerne les
étudiants et le prix de la scolarité
dans les universités britanniques
les britanniques qui résident dans les
pays en dehors du royaume uni ii les
parents les familles ne soient pas payés
ou tarif étrangers qui est le double du
tarif des fins domestiques jusqu'à
maintenant c'était l'intérêt de
domestique par ailleurs il ya le
problème de la 2 droit que du droit de
coin perdu de s'établir dans un autre
pays membre de l'union
la une les britanniques qui sont établis
dans les pays de l'union à 27 risque de
se voir enfin deux de ne pas pouvoir
progresser professionnellement
si pour les employeurs pour les clients
en ce qui concerne les libéraux c'est
plus difficile
de s'établir dans un autre pays
j'ai des collègues qui partent qu'ils
changent de pays tous les 2-3 ans là ce
sera beaucoup plus difficile pour pour
ces gens là un sujet qui sera au coeur
donc eu des négociations on a entendu
michel barnier il ya quelques instants
rappelé avec fermeté que l'accès du
royaume uni au marché européen devra
respecter un certain nombre de règles
de son côté me boris johnson rejette un
alignement sur l'union européenne
chacun hafiz donc ses jo effectif d'apr
disney gociations à venir un pack wii
c'est le premier jour un donc chacun
affiche ses objectifs qui sont assez
assez loin les uns des autres
c'est vrai que et tous les deux une
championne et monsieur barnier ce qu'ils
disent et c'est exactement ce à quoi on
s'attend donc on verra bien dans l'est
dans les prochains mois en tout cas ça
donne selon vous est-ce que ça va
pouvoir les positions des uns et des
autres vont pouvoir s'assouplir et
devront ça ne servirait à rien de se
regarder en chiens de faïence et de ne
pas assouplir sa position événements
tristes hier à londres l'attaqué
revendiquée par l'état islamique cela
rappelle également la question de la
sécurité qui reste au premier plan
quel compromis pour vous devront être
trouvés sur ce sujet de la sécurité là
il faut pas qu'il y ait des conduits là
il faut qu'il y ait un accord solide
parce que c'est vrai que un des
problèmes qui
qui ça parmi les problèmes qui
surviennent à la suite de la sortie du
rmi il ya ce cette question de la
coopération en matière sécuritaire et là
il faut vraiment que les gaulois est
muni et les pays bas l union européenne
soit bien soudée sur ces questions il y
a eu également on l'a vu dans le sujet
la question de la pêche
oui le royaume-uni est en position de
force sur cette question là comment
l'europe devra négocier selon vous cette
cette question de la pêche sur les
questions de la pêche il faut passer je
vous rappeler que la grande partie
d'eads et de la pêche péché par les
britanniques dans les mers britannique
est exporté vers l'union et la france
notamment
mais d'autres pays de l'union donc
magique la majorité de la pêche en était
que ça qu'on présente quatre cinquièmes
sont exportés a donc il faut faire
attention parce que c'est bien beau de
dire oui on va maîtriser nos eaux
territoriales mais il faut pouvoir
vendre sa production sa pêche ou
continuer à vendre donc sans droits de
douane si possible là il ya beaucoup de
contradictions tendance que dit monsieur
johnson s'est pas cette incohérence et
monsieur barnier a raison de parler de
cohérence oui il dit ils retrouveront à
ce que c'est pas le moment pour le
royaume uni de montrer un peu ses points
forts juive ne m'en ait pu poser dans
les négociations ou début de la
négociation bien sûr chacun montre ses
muscles l'europe en tout cas est-ce que
sur vous il est en position de force
en tout cas pour wii ont négocié oui je
pense parce que c'est tout de même ça
reste le bloc des changes de libre
échange le plus grand du monde c'est
beaucoup plus important que le marché
britannique
il faut pas se leurrer aussi on sait que
le système européen de marché unique
mise en place à l'initiative en grand
partie des britanniques il ya plus d'un
an
c'était ça on a besoin de ça pour les
échanges fluides et pour la continuité
de la fabrication de produits
industriels en flux tendu où sont nos
villes de construction d'avions et
beaucoup d'autres activités
la population britannique plus
particulièrement les populations les
plus populaires les plus pauvres selon
vous quel impact cette sortie du royaume
uni l'union européenne pourrait avoir
sur ces populations à ce qu elles vont
ressentir ce qu'il va y avoir des effets
dans leur quotidien il y aura il y
aurait des effets oui il y aurait des
effets vous savez que dans tous les cas
de figure les instituts économiques à
commencer par le fonds monétaire
international et d'autres d'autres
institutions prévoient une baisse de la
deûle à du produit national brut donc
dans tous les cas je crois que ça a été
dit ou parlement britannique cet après
midi on dit donc parler de -6 7% dans un
document gouvernemental qui date de 2018
- 6,7 pour cent dans le cas d'un accord
type canada et dans le cas d'un accord
type australien c'est à dire sans sonde
il un sens
où tout vous thème omc ou conditions omc
ce serait moins 9,3 pour cent voilà ce
que ceci afin d'accord on le rappelle
c'est l'om c'est qui qui qui arbitre oui
ce serait dans les dents les conditions
de l'om c'est donc sans sans accord
spécial du tout est là donc c'est des
baisses de 2 pnb qui sont considérables
il y a donc les accords avec l'union
européenne avec les états unis
comment est ce que va se comporter le
royaume uni c'est vous américains on a
bien entendu dans la bouche de monsieur
drop
je pense que ça va être comme un des six
fils difficile il ya il compte beaucoup
bon et johnson sur le sur les états unis
justement pour surmonter ce qui compte
beaucoup oui oui et on entend des il ya
des choses qui sont dites qu'ils sont
censés nous encourager vers un
changement des modes de consommation
donc le poulet qui il avait au chlore
aux états unis mais il ya d'autres
considérations qui qu'on n'a pas entendu
par exemple le ski on si on compare les
prix des décès dans la viande la longue
houle est d'un se dote ainsi je ne suis
pas marché moyen américain avec les prix
d'un supermarché moyens britannique
on voit que c'est plus cher aux états
unis donc un accord commercial n'est
jamais qu'un qu'une autorisation à
vendre ce n'est pas une le consommateur
n'est pas forcé d'acheter comme les les
produits pharmaceutiques
également on n'est pas le service
national de santé qui tarde grands
acheteurs de produits pharmaceutiques
n'est pas obligé ne peut pas obliger
d'acheter mais les creux du lait les
producteurs ont le dos rond les droits
auraient le droit de proposer leurs
produits mais il faut encore que le prix
soit attractif pour conclure en amour
onze mois de négociations trop court
selon vous à passer c'est très court oui
et puis c'est même pas 11 mois parce que
lors des venues déjà février il ya des
discussions entre les 27 du mandat dont
il faut mettre les 27 pays ensemble au
même diapason et puis à l'été il y assez
rythmée par les réunions du conseil
européen donc c'est octobre il faut
pratiquement avoir terminé en octobre
mars à octobre ces six mois c'est pas
merci beaucoup ont trouvé à christopher
chantre et d'avoir accepté notre
invitation des règles sur rt franc je
rappelle que vous êtes vice-président de
l'association british community
committee of france à la visite des
manuels macron en pologne maintenant on
le sait il ne partage pas les mêmes
idées que son homologue andrei dauda mai
lors d'une conférence de presse
il a salué cet après-midi un tournant
dans les relations avec la pologne au
moment où le royaume uni on en parlait à
l'instant quitte l'union européenne au
cours de cette visite de deux jours il
sera aussi question de coopération
militaire ou encore d'énergie nucléaire
et renouvelables et sur le sujet du
climat justement varsovie et paris n'ont
pas toujours été d'accord on le rappelle
emmanuel macron s'était agacé du blocage
de la pologne alors réticent à l'idée
d'inscrire à l'agenda européen
l'objectif de neutralité carbone pour
2050 une visite en pologne au cours de
laquelle emmanuel macron a également
évoqué la russie un voisin de l'union
européenne avec qui il est nécessaire de
composer écoutez le la france n'est ni
pro russe ni anti russe elle est pro
européenne et il se trouve que quand je
regarde une carte et je crois que vous
avez le même sentiment quand vous la
regardez monsieur le président on voit
très clairement que la russie est en
europe même si elle n'est pas dans
l'union européenne et qu'elle est dans
notre voisinage et que nous n'avons
aucun intérêt à avoir une situation qui
consiste à ne pas regarder en face
notre relation avec la russie et a
laissé des conflits je laisse accumulés
ou des malentendus là aussi se
poursuivre je n'ai absolument aucune
naïveté mais je sais que dans l'intérêt
de la sécurité de l'europe de la france
comme de la pologne
nous devons avoir un dialogue politique
exigeant avec la russie et pour en
parler claude blanchemaison expert en
relations internationales nous a rejoint
sur ce plateau claude
ils ont bonsoir hachoir merci d'être
avec nous en direction arte france
alors pourquoi emmanuel macron ce
rentier en pologne maintenant on va
écouter aujourd'hui la pologne est au
coeur de l'europe
elle est au coeur de l'europe évidemment
puisqu'elle a rejoint l'union européenne
en 2004 avec d'autres pays d'europe de
l'est et qu'elle est parmi ces pays qui
ont rejoint en 2004 le pays le plus
important le plus puissant même sur le
plan économique la pologne a été un état
membre exemplaires depuis 15 ans
puisqu'elle ces réformes est pour
pouvoir bénéficier au maximum des fonds
structurels européens à l'époque et pas
d'autoroute y avait pas de transport
moderne en pologne aujourd'hui il ya les
autoroutes et des transports modernes
partout l'agriculture a énormément
progressé
avec l'aide des fonds européens des
fonds structurels européens
et puis la pologne est une vieille amie
de la france ça n'est pas nouveau c'est
pas nécessaire de remonter au grand
duché de varsovie
la france a toujours été l'ami de la
pologne et pendant l'époque un peu
sombre pour la population polonaise que
lorsque lech walesa était syndicaliste
aux chantiers de gdansk
après tout c'est l'époque où les
intellectuels polonais venaient à paris
enseigné à la sorbonne à l'école
pratique des hautes études et avaient
leurs habitudes à paris et paris étaient
en effet dans l'esprit de tous les
polonais alors c'est un peu tout ça qui
est en quête en jeu aujourd'hui est en
effet emmanuel macron a signé un accord
de partenariat stratégique pour dans la
perspective en effet 2
faire des progrès sur la construction
européenne justement quels sont les
dossiers les sujets aujourd'hui qui
rapproche la france et la pologne a dans
les mains qui est évidente on parle pas
souvent c'est le maintien des principes
de la politique agricole commune
c'est une invention française dit on ça
a beaucoup profité à l'agriculture
allemand dans le passé ça a profité à
tous les états membres
et depuis quinze ans ça profite beaucoup
à la pologne un certain nombre d'étapes
pense que cette politique devrait être
démantelée ou en tout cas que elle coûte
trop cher et il va y avoir en effet dans
les prochaines années une renégociation
des principes de la politique agricole
commune pour la verdir si j'ose dire la
verdir au carré et c'est à dire en faire
une politique écologique
bien sûr il faut qu'elle devienne plus
écologique mais sur ce sujet de la
politique agricole commune je pense
qu'il ya un point commun entre la france
et la pologne
bien sûr il ya aussi le réchauffement
climatique c'est un sujet délicat
difficile puisque la pologne à une
économie où le charbon rejoint un rôle
clé c'est un héritage il faut en tenir
compte il faut ménager les transitions
et il faut tout rediscuter
je crois que les deux présidents ont
parlé aussi de d'un char du futur donc
une coopération dans le domaine
militaire
et puis bien sûr il y à la coopération
triangulaire entre la france la pologne
et l'allemagne et pour des raisons un
petit peu inconnu ce format ne s'est pas
réuni depuis très longtemps et je crois
que les deux présidents ont décidé que
il convenait de ressusciter ce format de
weimar avec la chancelière
le président français et les
responsables polonais vous parliez d'une
collaboration militaire avec un nouveau
char en perspective
quelle est la place justement
aujourd'hui de la pologne au niveau
sécuritaire en europe alors la pologne
évidemment attache beaucoup d'importance
à l'otan c'était un secret pour personne
et son histoire évidemment fait
comprendre pourquoi la pologne atteint
aujourd'hui les 2% de pnb en dépenses
militaires son budget militaire
représente 2% de son de son pnb ce qui
est l'engagement de des pays qui
participent à l'otan alors sur ce sujet
je crois que la pologne était un peu
inquiète des propos tenus par monsieur
macron lorsqu'il a rappelé est que
l'otan était en état de mort cérébrale
un seul à inquiéter la volga
demande alors peut-être que c'était pour
équilibrer une expression un peu
différente mais que voulez dire la même
chose des manuels trump lorsqu'il est
arrivé au pouvoir est manal trump a dîné
tous il est obsolète après donald 30
pardon a dit neto est obsolète
c'est-à-dire l'otan c'est dépassé c'est
ringard alors qu'est ce que ça voulait
dire exactement
bien sûr les collaborateurs de monsieur
trump ont corrigé immédiatement dans les
jours qui suivent
mais il n'empêche qu'on sait que
monsieur trappe ne porte pas dans son
coeur
les organisations multilatérales et
notamment l'otan et préfèrent les
alliances bilatérales est pour lui une
alliance bilatérales c'est assez simple
vous achetez du matériel militaire
américain et vous acceptez le
commandement d'un général américain est
assez simple comme fonctionnement on
entendait le président emmanuel macron
il ya quelques instants déclaré la
france n'est ni pro russe ni anti
russell et pro européenne
il a également prôné lundi un dialogue
politique exigeant avec elle la russie
comment le rapprochement entre la france
et la russie depuis 2017 a été perçu par
la pologne est une crainte on l'a senti
oui là aussi c'est comme pour le temps
il ya une méfiance bien entendu et là je
pense que les propos du président de la
république ont rassuré les polonais le
fait que probablement il y aura une
rencontre en forme à weimar avec
l'allemagne est aussi de nature à les
rassurer
parce que bien sûr il faut que les
polonais participent d'une manière ou
d'une autre à ce dialogue et que quels
que soient leur prévention pour des
raisons historiques bien compréhensible
vis-à-vis de moscou il puis ils ont
d'ailleurs un dialogue avec moscou
il ya des rapports qui existent avec
moscou quels sont ils d'ailleurs
économiquement
voilà peut-être faut-il que c'est que
ces rapports soient soit plus plus
vivant et plus avec moins de
sous-entendus et peut-être que là aussi
la france et l'allemagne peuvent peuvent
y aider en quoi le départ du royaume uni
de l'union européenne finalement rebâti
les cartes et notamment pour la pologne
je pense que le départ de lurian grande
bretagne en effet modifier la situation
c'est pas une bonne nouvelle
il faut pas le cacher pour pour l'union
européenne mais tout le monde est
d'accord pour dire que la coopération
militaire qui a existé avec la grande
bretagne devra continuer elle ne se
faisait pas dans le schéma à l'intérieur
des institutions de l'union européenne
donc le départ de l'union européenne
n'implique pas la fin de la coopération
militaire avec la grande bretagne
donc cette coopération militaire
européenne avec la grande-bretagne
bilatérales avec la grande-bretagne
continuera et se développera maintenant
il est probable que la négociation feu
sur le régime définitif des entre la
grande bretagne et l'union européenne va
être une négociation difficile et on en
a vu aujourd'hui les prémices puisque
dans les déclarations des négociateurs
on a très clairement vu que bien sûr si
le royaume uni n'applique pas les
conditions de concurrence de faire comme
péter chaînes comme un comédien monsieur
barnier
eh bien il n'y a pas de raison qu'il est
un libre accès au marché commun au
marché européen
donc il faut que les conditions de
concurrence soient les mêmes sur le plan
écologique sur le plan social sur le
plan fiscal
si on à singapour sur la table et les
pas possible de lui accorder un libre
accès au marché continental et bien
d'autres dossiers aussi crispé les
relations c'est celui de la migration
quelle est la différence de vision entre
les deux pays la pologne et la france
sur cette question
migration sur la question de la
migration la france est plus proche
géographiquement des pays qui reçoivent
les flux migratoires du sud notamment de
du sahel à travers la libye à travers la
tunisie à travers la mer méditerranée et
ces migrants lorsqu'il ne meurt pas en
cours de route arrive en espagne en
italie ou en grèce est bon il est assez
légitime que les autres pays de l'union
européenne porte une partie de ce
fardeau et ne laisse pas uniquement sur
les épaules et premier recevant c'est à
dire des premiers récipiendaires
c'est à dire de l'espagne de l'italie et
de la grèce par conséquent la commission
a eu l'idée d'une répartition des quotas
les pays d'europe de l'est d'une façon
générale les polonais en particulier ne
veulent pas entendre parler de quotas
donc c'est une déco ciation qui doit se
poursuivre mais bien entendu il faut
discuter du partage du fardeau parce que
ce fardeau ne peut pas être portée
exclusivement par les pays du sud
est ce que pour conclure ce voyage cette
visite d' emmanuel macron en pologne va
également rayonner autour dans les
autres pays de l'europe de l'est
oui je pense que oui mais encore une
fois je crois que la pologne est un pays
très particulier c'est un pays très
important c'est un pays clé et bien sûr
la république tchèque la slovaquie la
hongrie sont aussi des pays importants
et mais je crois que la clé de tous ces
pays passe par varsovie
merci beaucoup claude blanchemaison
d'avoir partagé votre analyse en direct
sur notre plateau fille et dans quelques
instants nous reviendrons sur la réforme
des retraites robe noire et blouses
blanches ont défilé aujourd'hui à paris
pour conserver leur caisse de retraite
autonome puis direction les états unis
avec un premier rendez vous électoral
important dans l'iowa pour les
potentiels candidats à la maison blanche
surtout côté démocrate
restez avec nous sur rt france
[Musique]
le foot us qu est ce que c est ce que
c'est du sport est ce que c'est de la
politique
est-ce que c'est du business pense que
vous auriez même peut-être pu ajouter
est ce qu'il s'agit de religion c'est un
spectacle qui a conquis l'amérique au
cours des cinquante soixante dix
dernières années et qui est devenu le
premier spectacle télévisuel aux états
unis depuis notre vingtaine d'années
quand il ya plus de 110 millions de
téléspectateurs le super bowl devient un
vecteur de communication
ce qui est intéressant c'est que ils ont
mis au milieu de ce spectacle sportif et
politique le sport qui fait qu'il ya du
contenu les américains aiment pas
beaucoup quand le sport et la politique
se mêlant le sport n'est pas juste un
sanctuaire le sport on va représenter
notre société et si la société est
raciste et bien à un moment on va se
rendre compte que dans le sport il ya du
racisme
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes
coups politiques n'a jamais été obligé
de dire la veille d idée courageuse des
mots qui compte onze soir vient de
l'ignorance
aujourd'hui on a une gauche qui présente
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
[Musique]
le week-end geoffroy deux frères animé
par leur passion pour l'eau ont décidé
d'emprunter les routes de la soie sur
les traces des premiers échanges entre
les civilisations
en quatre mois de la chine à paris et
parcours sur leur side car plus de 15000
kilomètres à travers l'asie centrale et
l'asie mineure pour revivre l'évolution
du commerce mondial et son impact sur la
ressource en eau
[Musique]
et ah oui ce que j'aime pas c'est quand
je vais à l'école d'un côté il ya
beaucoup de policiers et de l'autre des
bandits
[Musique]
j'étais la russie était la rue nous
parlant au nom des enfants morts il doit
payer pour ses crimes
c'était un crime barbare horrible il
payera autant qu'elle a fait souffrir
mon fils
azarov lors du premier jour de
l'opération nous avons trouvé sept
victimes de meurtres dans le quartier
mais ce n'était pas des victimes de
l'opération pour ce jeu policière
ok allons-y
[Musique]
qui
je
la rivière tout moche you au delà du
cours moyen fonctions
et elle s'est inclinée pour saluer le
propriétaire du tout menace en
traditionnel et à la demande et fait
cesser cette tempête de neige sinon mon
peuple mourra
[Musique]
aussi on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
[Musique]
ici on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit c'est comme on voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
parce qu'ici c'est interdit d'interdire
bonsoir et bienvenue sur rt france si
vous nous rejoignez il est 20h30 heure
de paris une réforme des retraites qui
est loin de faire l'unanimité au moment
où le texte est examiné à l'assemblée
une nouvelle manifestation a eu lieu à
paris ce lundi le cortège est parti de
la place de la bastille et à rallier la
place de l'opéra les professions
libérales comme les avocats
elle dénonce une réforme qui augmentera
leur cotisation le point avec katia
technique
la manifestation du 3 janvier à l'appel
du collectif sos retraites a mobilisé
des milliers d'avocats et de professions
libérales à travers la france ils se
sont tous déplacés
tous les barreaux était représenté il le
conteste cette réforme des retraites qui
les obligera à augmenter les cotisations
par exemple pour les avocats c'est
cotisation passerait de 14 à 28 % alors
que distillent leur caisse fonctionne
parfaitement elle est même excédentaire
je vous propose d'écouter quelques
avocats croisés sur le parcours pour ce
qui concerne la route
bancables une centaine gagnent moins de
1000 euros par mois et quand on est
doublement des cotisations passage à 14
à 22 %
un certain nombre de cabinets vont
devoir mourir et les personnels sont
menacés il faut faire comme les avocats
parce que nous on a un système qui
fonctionne donc il faudrait que tout le
monde se met au régime autonome et il y
aurait plus de problème de retraite en
france il ya quand même un grand
paradoxe aujourd'hui dans le discours
c'est que on a une caisse qui fonctionne
parfaitement et on veut la supprimer
pour entrer dans un régime que l'on sait
qu'il n'a pas fonctionné parce que le
système de la solidarité aujourd'hui ça
ne marche plus les gens n'y croient plus
donc il faut des régimes autonome voilà
il se trouve qu'on a des réserves qu'on
est excédentaire alors peut-être que
c'est ça qui l'intéressent
effectivement sans chose la question
quand même mais ses réserves
on les a constitué que les cotisations
nos confrères nous servent à alimenter
nous un fonds de solidarité entre nous
ce qui fait que ça nous permet d'avoir
quelques oeufs soit l'avocat son
activité avoir une retraite minimum
identique à tous des milliers d'avocats
et de professions libérales comme des
soignants des médecins également des
pilotes les experts comptables et est
aujourd'hui à paris de bastille à opéra
pour se plaindre de cette réforme pour
la contester augmentation des
cotisations je les dis mais également
baisse des pensions à prévoir christiane
féral-schuhl qui est la présidente du
conseil national des barreaux estime que
cette cette réforme et à rejeter dans
son ensemble je vous propose de
l'écouter cette réforme de la retraite
c'est elle
réforme de trop et
mal engagés pas abouti et d'ailleurs
hier au sujet vous savez tous la durée
du congé parental de cinq à douze jours
la ministre du travail a indiqué comme
vote se justifier parce qu'on savait pas
comment financer les le fait de passer
de cinq à douze jours donc a fortiori on
peut imaginer que la réforme des
retraites qui est la réforme dont on
vous dit qu'elle est la plus importante
depuis son temps eh bien on n'a pas de
garanties sur le financement et nous ça
va mettre en difficulté au moins 50 % de
la profession d'avocat mais ça va mettre
en difficulté l'ensemble des professions
libérales
prenez le cas des infirmiers et des
infirmières j'ai discuté avec des
kinésithérapeutes avec des
ergothérapeutes
alors soit on décide de supprimer ces
métiers mais ce sont des métiers de
proximité
donc cette mobilisation s'est rappelé la
place qu'occupe
c'est profession nous sommes 18
profession rassembler et nous aimons
notre métier notre engagement à
l'arrivée à opérant un cortège s'est
détachée notamment les avocats du
barreau de lyon et ils ont tenté une
action ils sont arrivés près de la place
vendôme pourquoi parce que c'est le lieu
du ministère de la justice ils ont
réclamé la démission de nicole belloubet
la garde des sceaux
je rappelle que les 18 professions
concernées aujourd'hui qu'ils étaient
dans cette manifestation sont en grève
glissante depuis le 3 janvier
pour les avocats c'est une date un peu
fatidique puisque demain mardi
ils ont rendez vous avec le premier
ministre edouard philippe
pour négocier encore au sujet cette
réforme ou carrément demandé de la
retirer alors beaucoup d'avocats
aujourd'hui mais aussi des médecins
libéraux des kinés des podologues mais
aussi des des infirmières et pour en
parler nous sommes avec jérôme marty
médecin généraliste président de l'union
française pour une médecine libre et
membre du collectif sos retraite jérôme
marty bonsoir bonsoir merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation sur rt france
nouvelle journée de mobilisation
aujourd'hui pour les médecins libéraux
également vous voulez maintenir la
pression va bien sûr on est engagé dans
un combat qui va être un combat long
mais qui est un combat primordial parce
que cette réforme est extrêmement
dangereuse pour l'ensemble de nos
professions du soin elle est dangereuse
pour les médecins mais elle est
dangereuse pour l'ensemble des
paramédicaux et donc elle est dangereuse
pour les français parce que elle va
entraîner une casse très importante dans
nos professions et donc on va se dire on
est en droit de se demander qui va vous
soigner de même très concrètement qu'est
ce qui va se passer si cette réforme de
retraites et mise en place qu'est ce qui
va se passer pour un médecin généraliste
qui s'est installé deux exemples très
simple pour les paramédicaux c'est la
même problématique que pour les avocats
c'est à dire que leurs cotisations vont
passer de 14 à 28 % et ce sont des
professions que les tarifs qui sont
comme pour les médecins au plus bas de
la moyenne européenne ils ne pourront
pas faire face à ses charges et donc des
centaines et des centaines de cabinets
vont fermer et pour les médecins ce sont
les pensions qui vont diminuer de 30 à
34 %
donc ça veut dire qu un tiers des 2 du
sud
du bénéfice peine un tiers un tiers de
la manne économique des retraites va
diminuer va diminuer et ça on ne pourra
pas y faire face donc plus ça va baisser
l'attractivité de nos professions qui
dit baisse d'attractivité dit que moins
de médecins - s'installer donc plus de
déserts médicaux et ses os etc l'hôpital
va très mal aussi que les urgences vont
très mal on sait que la médecine de
ville va très mal fait un bref on se
demande s'il ya un endroit dans le soin
qui ne va pas mal suite à la gestion de
l'état et semer meta prétend pouvoir
gérer nos retraites mais nous nous avons
la faiblesse de lui dire non nous ne
vous croyons pas parce que nous ne
pouvons pas signer un contrat qui est un
contrat léonin puisque vous me dites
vous vous devez vous amenez vos réserves
et l'état lui ne nous amène que de la
baisse donc d'un contrat léonin
les avocats vont être reçus demain
demain soir à matignon les médecins est
ce que vous êtes en contact avec le
gouvernement il ya une réunion de prévue
prochainement
il ya des réunions qui sont faites avec
un à deux syndicats qui à mon avis se
trompent énormément parce que ils font
confiance encore à cette réforme alors
que vous l'avez vue là la grande
majorité des professionnels libéraux
quels qu'ils soient n'ont pas confiance
parce qu'encore une fois cette réforme
représente un réel danger il faut savoir
que nos professions sont des professions
aujourd'hui fragilisée tous les patients
de france le vivent et on ne peut pas se
permettre d'aller vers une réforme qui
risque de fragiliser un peu plus
aujourd'hui
comment est ce qu'elle est gérée la
retraite des médecins libéraux et des
professions libérales paramédical
comment est-ce que c'est déjà loin des
avocats nous avons comme les avocats
nous avons des caisses qui sont des
caisses autonomes c'est à dire que
normalement nous ne sommes pas concernés
par cette réforme cette réforme concerne
le régime général et ce régime général
nous en avons été exclus à ça quand on
l'a mis en place en 45
donc nous avons mis en place nous des
caisses autonomes qu'ils soient
solidarité professionnelle où chaque
médecin cotisent pour les médecins les
infirmières cotisent pour les
infirmières etc etc
nous avons géré en bon père de famille
et nous avons su faire face aux erreurs
politiques qui ont amené la chute
démographique en acceptant de cotiser
plus et de recevoir moins pour
constituer les réserves ses réserves en
totalité il faut savoir que ça
représente quand même 130 milliards pour
l'ensemble des populations
donc les deux des populations libéral
donc on est en face de quoi on est en
face d'un hold up en col blanc
votre argent videmment clorinda on veut
récupérer épreuve année d'ailleurs que
l'état nous dit les réserves vont me
servir à organiser la transition vers le
nouveau système mais c'est pas ça
qu'elles servent les réserves les
réserves elles servent à faire face au
trou démographique
elles servent à payer des pensions elles
ne servent pas à payer des cotisations
va pas payer des cotisations et des
cotisations alors c'est bien que ce
gouvernement a une façon très curieuse
de gérer puisque là les députés
discutent d'une réforme dont ils n'ont
ni les tenants ni les aboutissants
matière financière ces 15 h ordinaire et
cette idée d'une réforme plus juste plus
solidaire
défendu par le gouvernement vous en
pensez quoi je pense que c'est du pipeau
passez moi le mot elle n'est ni juste ni
solidaire pas juste parce que elle
représente un réel danger de fermeture
pour nos cabinets parce que la paire et
notre pérennité économique et mise en
danger et elle n'est absolument pas les
nids solidaire ni sage nous nous sommes
solidaires nous abondons des caisses qui
sont déficitaires et nous ne comptons
pas un rond à l'état pains et là on veut
nous on veut nous faire croire que
régime universel va être solidaire il va
pas être solidaire ça va être un régime
à points dans les points vont être
définies par le parlement et ces points
vont varier en fonction de l'état
économique du pays et force est de
constater que depuis 30 ans notre pays
va mal sur le plan économique dont colin
du souci à se faire
le débat parlementaire a débuté
aujourd'hui on l'a vu ils risquent
d'être houleux est ce que vous craignez
un éventuel passage en force du
gouvernement
ils devraient finir on peut le craindre
ça c'est certain mais à mon avis ça
serait la dernière chose à faire on a
des élections municipales qui sont
extrêmement proches
immédiatement derrière il ya les
élections présidentielles le temps passe
très vite vouloir imposer cette réforme
à des gens qui voient quatre fois la
population française chaque année qu'un
taux de confiance entre 84 81 90 % et
donc une réelle influence de conseil sur
les gens ça serait à mon avis prendre
beaucoup beaucoup de risques alors il ya
eu des milliers d'amendements notamment
de la part de
de la france insoumise pour vous c'est
une bonne tactique tactique dangereuse
comment est ce que vous le percevez
rangs des parlementaires je crois que
j'ai entendu le gouvernement dira que
c'était pas démocratique au contraire je
crois que c'est quelque chose de très
démocratique ça ouvre à la discussion
force est de constater qu'il n'y a eu
aucune discussion
quel sens vous avez que vous avez vu
venir très concrètement il est vrai
média les mauvaises après le dialogue il
ya eu des réunions avec des explications
n'avaient des paper board et les
powerpoint ou leurs représentants du
gouvernement monsieur delevoye dont on
sait comment dans quelles conditions il
est parti puis monsieur pitre avait ce
qui faisait venez présenter leurs
réformes et n'écoutez pas n'écoutez pas
ce qu'on leur disait et preuve en est
que les gens qui dirigent nos caisses
autonomes ont été proprement foutu
dehors de ces discussions à la deuxième
réunion parce qu'il contredisait le
gouvernement voilà comment le
gouvernement conçoit le dialogue vous
n'avez pas été écoutés c'est ça
aujourd'hui ce que vous reprochez au
gouvernement oui mais sur du coup quelle
suite
quelle action vous à vous avez prévu à
l'avenir justement pour toujours lutter
contre ces belles déjà il souhaite
retraite grossistes mouvement qui est un
mouvement pluriprofessionnelle vous le
savez de paramédicaux de métiers du
chiffre de métiers du transport de
métiers de la justice et de la santé
de nouveaux syndicats se sont agrégés il
y à une union qui se crée donc on va
effectivement continuer à faire des
actions mobilisation dans les rues arrêt
et sans doute de 2,2 tout ce qui est
administratif dans nos professions comme
ça se passe à l'hôpital actuellement
et puis sans doute d'autres d'autres
actions on part pour un come back est un
combat long merci beaucoup jérôme marty
d'avoir accepté notre invitation je
rappelle que vous êtes médecin
généraliste président de l'union
française pour une médecine libre et
membre du collectif sos retraite merci à
vous jour j aux états unis la primaire
démocrate à commencer par le caucus de
l'iowa une élection atypique au cours de
laquelle à main levée seront désignés
est des délégués se sont eux qui
choisiront le candidat démocrate
une étape incontournable et très
déterminante explications avec françois
tisci est vite chez hgrégoire d'auxerre
dans un caucus pas d'isoloir mais des
règles bien spécifiques
les sympathisants se réunissent dans
différentes salles et coll
gymnase de l'état john thys
organisateurs du caucus pour les
démocrates du comté de johnson explique
ce processus particulier nous avons ici
un auditorium divisé en sections
c'est une belle division naturel ainsi
le président peut mettre bernie si
warren ici boutih gaig là bas vous
pouvez voir de belles pelouses en clair
les personnes choisissent en quelque
sorte leur coin brandissent leurs
pancartes
et il se dirige vers l'endroit où ils
sont attirés il faut obtenir 15% de la
salle pour pouvoir être éligible
c'est ce qu'on appelle la viabilité les
grands groupes peuvent donc envoyer des
délégués au niveau suivant
puis il ya plusieurs niveaux avant
d'arriver à la convention nationale de
milwaukee mais plus petit groupe doit
faire en second choix et ils peuvent
soit le faire en fonction de leur
deuxième favori soit en fonction du
candidat qu'ils veulent sanctionner le
plus grand suspense règne les quatre
favoris restent relativement proches
dans les sondages dernier sanders en
tête suivi de l'ancien vice président
joe biden
pique boufigue un prix et les abattoirs
n une campagne tronquée par le procès en
destitution de donald trump à washington
privant certains candidats siégeant au
sénat de plusieurs meetings ces
dernières semaines les dernières heures
sont cruciales
des habitants de l'iowa nombreux
démocrates hésitent encore il se peut
qu'il y ait un candidat plus que les
autres et s'ils répondent un sondage ils
peuvent exprimer cette préférence les
beaucoup d'entre eux sont encore indécis
il essaie de prendre une décision finale
avant de participer au caucus est donc
la dernière vague de miti la dernière
vague de publicité les dernières
prospectus pourrait être ce qui va faire
changer d'avis certaines personnes
signe que la tension monte à la proche
du vote
un sondage très attendue d'un journal de
référence dans l'iowa n'a pas été publié
comme prévu samedi soir l'équipe de
pique boufigue et ayant soulevé des
doutes sur la façon dont ils avaient été
menées à rots dans l'iowa qui pourrait
d'ores et déjà s'avérer cruciale pour
les démocrates
depuis bill clinton en 1996 des
vainqueurs des caucus de l'iowa ont
toujours remporté la primaire
et concernant cette primaire démocrate
les derniers sondages sont très serrés
parmi les favoris trois poids lourds du
parti mais aussi de nouveaux visages qui
pourrait apporter un nouveau souffle
nécessaire à une victoire démocrate face
au candidat républicain donald trump
cécilia chaud le favori jo byden 77 ans
8 ans auprès de barack obama à la maison
blanche ont assuré une solide
crédibilité à l'ancien vice président
des états unis depuis son entrée en lice
en avril il se maintient en tête des
sondages mais c'est traditionnel gaffe
préoccupe
si je suis le candidat je le battrai
comme un tambour
s'il ne fait pas de bons scores dans
l'iowa et le new hampshire les deux
premiers états à voter il perdra son
statut de favori deuxième grande figure
démocrate le sénateur bernie sanders 78
en premier dans les sondages de l'iowa
grâce à des levées de fonds record à
grand soutien des jeunes et malgré une
crise cardiaque à l'automne 2010 9 celui
qui appelle à une révolution politique
pour une société plus juste et ferait
une partie de l'électorat démocrate
premières figures féminines la sénatrice
elizabeth warren 77 ans est classée
troisième dans les sondages nationaux
après avoir été jusqu'à menacer le
favori jo byden dans les intentions de
vote cet ancien républicaine
pourfendeuse de wall street a perdu la
faveur des électeurs pour avoir trop
tergiverser sur la question de la
réforme de la santé est essentielle aux
états unis
première surprise de cette campagne
pique boufigue 1 38 ans homosexuel
fervent croyant diplômés de
prestigieuses universités mais sans
expérience au niveau national et son
soutien dans le parti ce maire d'une
petite ville du midwest a aussi servi en
afghanistan
chaque fois que mon parti a gagné la
maison blanche au cours des 50 dernières
années c'est avec le candidat qui était
nouveau dans la politique nationale
concentrer sur l'avenir
a pris dans les voix de washington et
ouvrant la porte à une nouvelle
génération de leadership voilà comment
nous gagnons cinquième dans les sondages
nationaux il est troisième dans l'iowa
s'il était élu il deviendrait le plus
jeune président de l'histoire des états
unis
seconde femme amy klobuchar 59 ans est
sénatrice du minnesota petite fille d'un
mineur est avec elizabeth warren l'autre
favorite assumé du puissant quotidien
new york times en cinquième position
dans l'iowa
elle ne parvient pas à séduire sur le
plan national le seul candidat d'origine
asiatique encore inconnu il y a un an
l'homme d'affaires andrew yang 45 ans
s'est fait connaître avec une
proposition un revenu universel mensuel
de 1000 $ pour tous les américains
enfin michael bloomberg 77 ans quatrième
dans les sondages au niveau national est
bien connu du public ce milliardaire
ancien maire de new york
ex républicain puis indépendants se
démarque avec une stratégie inédite
faire l'impasse sur les votes des quatre
premiers états il ne se présente qu'à
partir du super tuesday le 3 mars
lorsqu'une quinzaine d'états votre ou et
pour en parler austin peterson écrivain
activiste politique est avec nous en
direct depuis jefferson city c'est notre
rubrique vu de l'extérieur
[Musique]
austin peterson bonjour merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france alors
seulement 1% des américains vivent dans
l'iowa
expliquez-nous le rôle de cet état dans
la présidentielle américaine et le
premier caucus de l'année c'est donc
cette europe est 15 fois le plus gros
test pour les élections c'est très
souvent le cas car à la démographie de
miyowa est très large et représente
beaucoup de philosophie d'une logique
politique dans les états unis la grèce
compte tenu des régions rurales
on ne peut avoir plus de soutiens pour
des citoyens urbains
on a aussi beaucoup d'universités dans
cet état donc il y aura beaucoup j'étais
jeune soutien du président du candidat
bernie sanders
il ya également beaucoup de zones
rurales et les électeurs qui vont avec
eux ont tendance à choisir des dégâts
plus modérés comme tout bon teasing en
quoi la loi au fond reflètent ils
vraiment la diversité nationale
c'était fini depuis leur fondation sont
dans un pillard isme entre les états du
sud plutôt agricole et un autre plus tôt
donc
les valeurs dépendantes de cela et cela
dépend également du doubs les électeurs
vivre que ce soit un débit plus urbaine
ou plus rurales pour les etats unis
c'est un conflit très lointain très long
qui se reflète dans les partis en
fonction de l'origine des candidats de
la côte est ou de la californie par
exemple qu'ils auront des valeurs
différentes que des électeurs du midwest
du petit viège vient du midwest c'est
également un vétéran de l'armée
et bien qu'il soit ouvertement
homosexuel qui parfois peut poser
problème dans le midwest
il est très apprécié par les générations
les plus âgées avaient démocrates qui
sont progressifs mais qui sont reste
modérée dans certains autres aspects si
leur candidat préféré
la drogue se débrouille très bien dans
les régions rurales dans l'aube higway
ce temps d'autres dans des régions qui
ne sont pas comme la californie ou du
new york
ok on retrouve ces deux types
d'idéologie il ya des régions rurales et
des régions industrielles
alors on dit que les cocus sont de plus
en plus impopulaire pourquoi puis
balkans que ce spectacle aux gens aiment
les caucus parce que cela récompense les
candidats sur la base électorale est
dynamique il se présentera pour voter il
raconté à un caucus c'est faux que les
électeurs soient dévolus et qu'ils
soient prêts à rester pendant des heures
et des heures sur les lieux alors qu'ils
attentent le décompte des votes
il ya également plusieurs séries de vote
au cours de la journée et je pense que
c'est une belle façon de déterminer
la région géographique et la philosophie
des électeurs vis-à-vis de leurs
candidats les candidats qui ne sont pas
viables qui n'ont pas atteint le seuil
électoral peuvent y laisser leurs voix à
des candidats secondaire c'est une bonne
chose de pouvoir voter pour le constat
qu'il préfère et ensuite pouvoir choisir
d'autres ont préféré sinon alors qui
selon vous pour affronter donald trump
côté démocrate en matière de ressources
et j'ai dit et je ne suis qui est le
plus important en matière d'élection car
j'ai compté que deux fois et si je
n'avais pas cela je dirais que michael
bloomberg a les ressources et a les
idées afin de concourir
le problème que les sondages sont en sa
défaveur
les relations prochaine et le nevada
elle si joe biden il réussi à prendre
les devants on parle du sud alors il est
très possible que pour empêcher cet âge
ils ajoutent qu'ils vont essayer de
trouver des accords pourraient se
retrouver le véritable candidat c'est
vraiment la seule personne qui les
ressources financières et la réputation
tunis sociale afin d'obtenir beaucoup
d'électeurs aux états unis alors il ya
eu le procès en destitution donald trump
on en a beaucoup parlé
est ce que c'est un avantage un
désavantage pour donald trump selon vous
[Musique]
a pas beaucoup de désavantages enfin je
pense que son plus grand défi c'est
compte twitter mais cela peut être
facilement résolues
ce sont justement les avantages d'une
trentaine sont copiés les etats unis
sont très heureuses de 60 des actions de
la trappe qui sera très difficile pour
les démocrates de proposer des
politiques économiques
ils sont totalement opposées à celles du
donald trump tout en effet il est très
grave
aux etats unis qu un changement majeur
intervient maintenant
en règle générale le président sortant
est réélu aux états unis des primaires
démocrates sont en fait en marge de la
réélection de de latran mais d'un point
de vue objectif somme que ce sera le cas
alors pour conclure en hameaux quelles
vont être les prochaines étapes
importantes de cette campagne commencée
le yorkshire
après le caucus de liégeois ce sera une
primaire simple et intime que des brutes
est différent bien que bernie sanders
remporter ces primaires certains le
disent l'aspect intéressante de ce cycle
électoral
la réaction du parti biais nôtres at
face à dernier sanders et comme un
chantage et engranger des victoires
tricolores trois quatre voire cinq
lumières et qq ce alors la convention
nationale paniquera t il sans doute des
stratagèmes se mettront en place
d'empêcher la naissance d'heures
peut-être d'avoir l'investiture
merci beaucoup et austin pedersen
d'avoir partagé votre analyse en direct
sur rt frange rappelle que vous êtes
écrivain et activiste politique dans
quelques instants nous reviendrons sur
la visite du président français emmanuel
maradas est lui un tournant avec
varsovie puis retour en france où les
avocats ont à nouveau battu le pavé
aujourd'hui à paris ils poursuivent leur
contestation face au projet de réforme
des retraites rester avec nous sur rt
france
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous
s'il arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
saadi kadhafi
la société afghane ne permet pas aux
femmes d'être libres comme les hommes
les hommes peuvent faire ce qu'ils
veulent mais pas les femmes
[Musique]
nous avons encore besoin d'un garçon en
tout cas j'ai sept filles et pas de fils
en fait seules les filles qui viennent
chez nous et qui joue avec elles savent
que c'est une fille dehors quand elle
joue avec une balle
personne ne s'en rend compte que c'est
une fille et tout le monde croit que
c'est un garçon
[Musique]
les blanchons les bébés phoques du
groenland naissent sur la banquise de la
mer blanche
tout au long du xxème siècle les bébés
phoques ont été chassés pour leur
fourrure blanche comme neige
depuis que la chasse aux phoques est
interdite en russie il n'y a que les
touristes qui viennent voir ces animaux
à l'état sauvage
mais ces petits seront ils toujours en
sécurité
écoutez moi tout le monde si vous faites
trop de bruit je vais vous renvoyer dans
la salle de classe entendu certaines
personnes n'aiment pas le cirque
nous devons éveiller l'intérêt pour le
cirque chez les adultes et les enfants
pour les inciter à venir et à apprendre
[Musique]
eh bien eh bien les frais d'une main et
rattraper avec l'eau
[Musique]
je joue à quoi joue est important pour
un an
il ya eu un bombardement récemment tout
le monde a été tuée femmes vieillards et
enfants
tout a été détruit il ya un monde à
l'extérieur
il en existe un autre ici à l'intérieur
de ses murs
[Musique]
qu'est ce qui pousse tout simplement un
apnéiste à vouloir touchées les abymes
le but ultime c'est pas forcément de
gagner des médailles welsh podium c'est
d'arriver à gérer ses émotions dans un
certain environnement et et c'est un
univers qui nous permet justement
d'aller encore plus loin dans cet état
d'introspection et de travail sur le
corps et aussi sur l'esprit plus on va
être dans l'instant présent plus on va
être capable de gérer ce qu'on en a à
faire est concentré sur ce que l'on fait
ce que tu as confiance et la capacité à
vivre l'instant présent à être connectés
que sur ce qui se passe sur les sons sur
le toucher sur le ressenti et ça nous
pousse dans les retranchements à changer
des choses dans notre propre vie en
dehors de l'année
[Musique]
pour soi et merci de nous rejoindre en
direct sur rt france pour cette deuxième
heure d'information
il est 21h heure de paris tout de suite
les titres de l'actualité de ce lundi 3
février 2020 emmanuel macron salue un
tournant avec varsovie en visite en
pologne le chef de l'état veut apaiser
des relations tendues après la sortie du
royaume uni de l'union européenne il
souhaite rendre le projet européen plus
fort
une visite à la veille du 75e
anniversaire de la conférence de yalta
et qui avait eu lieu en crimée et durant
laquelle la carte de l'europe avait été
redessinée pour refléter les nouveaux
rapports de force issu de la seconde
guerre mondiale en france la réforme des
retraites continue a cristallisé les
débats les députés ont commencé à
examiner en commission spéciale le texte
de loi
l'occasion pour le collectif sos
retraite d'appeler à se mobiliser
plusieurs milliers de manifestants
avocat infirmiers kinés ou encore
stewart son défilé à paris il dénonce l
injustice de ce projet pour les
professions libérales
[Musique]
après le break site les négociations et
elles s'annoncent âpres entre le royaume
uni et l'union européenne
certaines questions sont en effet
susceptibles de ralentir voire de
bloquer les discussions à londres et
bruxelles dispose d'une période de
transition de 11 mois et chaque parti a
d'ores et déjà affiché ses objectifs et
défend ses intérêts après le divorce
quel accord trouvé est il possible d'en
trouver un
ce sera l'objet de notre face à face à
21h30
et tout de suite c'est la visite d'
emmanuel macron en pologne
wholesale ne partagent pas les mêmes
idées que son homologue andrei de duda a
néanmoins lors d'une conférence de
presse le chef d'état français a salué
un tournant dans les relations avec la
pologne au moment où le royaume uni
quitté l'union européenne
une visite de deux jours du président
français en pologne pour parler aussi de
coopération militaire ou encore
d'énergie nucléaire et renouvelables et
sur le sujet du climat varsovie et paris
n'ont pas toujours été d'accord on le
rappelle emmanuel macron s'était agacé
et du blocage de la pologne réticents à
l'idée d'inscrire à l'agenda européen
l'objectif de neutralité carbone pour
2050 une visite en pologne où emmanuel
macron a également évoqué la russie un
voisin l'union européenne avec qui il
est nécessaire de composer écoutez le la
france n'est ni pro russe ni anti russe
elle est pro européenne et il se trouve
que quand je regarde une carte et je
crois que vous avez le même sentiment
quand vous la regardez monsieur le
président on voit très clairement que la
russie est en europe même si elle n'est
pas dans l'union européenne et qu'elle
est dans notre voisinage et que nous
n'avons aucun intérêt à avoir une
situation qui consiste à ne pas regarder
en face notre relation avec la russie et
a laissé des conflits gelés s'accumuler
ou des malentendus là aussi se
poursuivre je n'ai absolument aucune
naïveté mais je sais que dans l'intérêt
de la sécurité de l'europe de la france
comme de la pologne
nous devons avoir un dialogue politique
exigeant avec la russie c'est demain que
se déroulera le 75e anniversaire de la
conférence de yalta cette réunion a
réuni les alliés les principaux
représentants des grandes puissances
mondiales
joseph staline pour l'union soviétique
winston churchill pour la grande
bretagne et franklin roosevelt pour les
états unis le général de gaulle est lui
le grand absent de ces négociations
explications en images
[Musique]
et
e
[Musique]
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
pierre emmanuel thomann fondateur d'euro
continent pierre-emmanuel thomann
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france alors la conférence de yalta qui
fête demain ses 75 ans reste dans
l'histoire des relations internationales
comme le monde du partage du monde entre
les grandes puissances et la création
d'onu 75 ans plus tard
est-ce qu'on assiste à une remise en
cause durable du multilatéralisme décidé
à yalta je crois qu'aujourd'hui
effectivement le multilatéralisme tel
qu'il est défendu par l'union européenne
est en crise mais c'est ce
multilatéralisme tel qu'il est défini
par l'union européenne est un
multilatéralisme idéologique c'est à
dire que dans les relations
internationales de plus en plus les
états devraient négocier au sein des
instances multilatérales comme l'onu les
nations unies l'union européenne la bce
est en fait jury 10 6 et les relations
internationales
appliquer des normes communes et ne plus
s'engager dans des rapports de force ou
des interventions militaires mais c'est
un grand rêve car le multilatéralisme ne
peut pas être mise en oeuvre sans une
multipolarité acceptable par les états
et aujourd'hui les la chine la russie
l'inde l'iran ne sont enfin tous les
tous les états en dehors de l'union
européenne ne sont pas d'accord sur
l'heure sur leur toit
la reconnaissance de leur propre poids
sur la scène internationale et sont sont
en faveur d'un multilatéralisme
mais qui ne soit pas une interprétation
unilatérale des pays occidentaux qui
dominait
guerre froide et la période de
l'après-guerre froide et donc sans son
multipolarité accepté c'est à dire un
meilleur équilibre entre états unis
russie chine et y compris au sein de
l'union européenne entre les différents
états européens il n'y aura pas de
négociation multilatérale possible ce
qu'ils ont voulu
effectivement le multilatéralisme est en
crise car nous n'avons pas encore les
états n'ont pas encore accepté le la
multipolarité qui petit à petit devrait
s'installer en europe et dans le monde
ce que vous nous dites c'est que l'état
d'esprit des accords de yalta a disparu
aujourd'hui
alors nous sommes dans un contexte très
différent les accords de yalta était
possible parce qu'on sortait de la
deuxième guerre mondiale
donc il y avait une guerre qui était
d'ailleurs en cours et les armées
soviétiques américaines en europe
rivalisaient pour se partager des zones
d'influencé et aujourd'hui nous sommes
plus dans ce cas là nous sommes dans une
période d'incertitude ou après la chute
du monde bipolaire
après la chute de la guerre froide est
une illusion pendant une vingtaine
d'années sur un monde unipolaire dominé
par l'excellent par l'occident c'est à
dire en réalité les états unis l'otan
l'union européenne
nous ne savons pas vers où nous allons
mais nous savons que les les états comme
la chine la russie et l'inde n'accepte
plus une vision unipolaire du monde et
donc les négociations sont difficiles
pour avoir une vision commune du
multilatéralisme et donc nous allons
plus de verre plus de molly type
multipolarité et eu un sommet comme il
yal'etat évidemment pour l'instant n'est
pas possible ce serait peut-être
nécessaire par exemple d'avoir une
nouvelle négociation
sur une nouvelle architecture européenne
de sécurité par exemple qui pourrait
faire l'état de grands sommets entre
tous les états européens qui pourrait
ressembler un petit peu à yalta en
négociant des zones d'affluence des
zones rouges stopper l'élargissement de
l'otan par exemple mais aujourd'hui on
voit que les états ne sont pas d'accord
et aujourd'hui le président français a
rencontré t en pologne j'ai les clameurs
de france par exemple ne sont pas sur
les mêmes finalités européennes ont des
visions rival alors justement pierre
emmanuel thomann le destin de la pologne
vous le rappeliez où le président
emmanuel macron est actuellement en
visite a aussi été décidée à yalta avec
1 re et d'équipement de ses frontières
est ce qu'aujourd'hui la pologne craint
perdre la protection de son grand frère
américain
je crois que la pologne met surtout en
avant une une vision dépassée qui avait
qui étaient qui avaient cours pendant la
grève forte c'est-à-dire la menace russe
une menace russe qui en fait n'existe
plus mais la pologne pour se positionner
comme comme puissance en europe centrale
et orientale est avéré avoir le soutien
des états unis pour sa propre puissance
à se positionne sur cette perception
alors même que la russie pour la france
n'est pas un ennemi et la france ne
considère qu'il n'y a pas de risque de
guerre avec la russie est au contraire
la france aimerait coopérer avec la
russie sur sur des domaines d'intérêt
commun et n'est engagé une nouvelle des
négociations sur une nouvelle
architecture européenne de sécurité
la pologne la pologne dans le projet
européen en fait considère l'union
européenne comme un projet surtout
économique
sa sécurité est à l'otan mais même si
l'otan qui est en crise s'affaiblissent
et la pologne est en alliance prend et
est en alliance avec les etats-unis
et lorsqu'on le regarde une carte la
pologne
en fait les intérêts des états unis en
europe d'ailleurs après le brésil c'est
sans doute son positionnement qu'elle va
mettre en avant la pologne par exemple
veut créer une zone tampon contre la
russie en soutenant le partenariat
talent d'où la crise avec l'ukraine et
les etats unis soutiennent la pologne
pour comme un état front avec les pays
baltes et là tu es là et l'ukraine pour
contenir poussée poussée à plus
d'influencé de l'otan vers l'eurasie
pour contenir la russie et la chine et
en même temps la russe la pologne aussi
à le projet d'initiative des trois
maires avec les pays d'europe centrale
et orientale de réorienter les
infrastructures énergétiques et de
transport nord-sud est pas est ouest
avec importations du gaz de schiste
américain donc en fait la pologne joue
le rôle de pivot dans la stratégie
américaine de d'utiliser l'europe compte
comme front contre la russie mer et la
chine est de couper en fait le lien
entre europe de l'ouest et russie alors
que la france a plutôt intérêt à une
vision plus continentale
voilà voilà le fondamental merci
beaucoup pierre emmanuel loman pour
votre analyse je rappelle que vous êtes
fondateur de re continent et on en vient
à la réforme des retraites toujours loin
de faire l'unanimité au moment où le
texte est examiné à l'assemblée
nationale ce sont les professions
libérales qui sont une nouvelle fois
descendus dans la rue aujourd'hui
et elle dénonce les conséquences de
cette réforme sur l'avenir de leur
profession ils étaient près de 15000
manifestants dans les rues de paris
selon le conseil national des barreaux
le cortège est parti de la place de la
bastille en début d'après-midi pour
terminer place de l'opéra sont dit
martin
une réforme qui divise autant qu'elle
unis ce sont près de dix-huit
professions libérales qui se sont réunis
dans les rues de paris
objectif dénoncer l'augmentation de
leurs cotisations
d'après ces professionnels la réforme
des retraites pourrait déclencher la
disparition d'un grand nombre
d'entreprises
une mobilisation entamée depuis près de
quatre semaines par les professionnels
de justice d'une cotisation 22%
certainement menacé j'ai quand même un
grand paradoxe aujourd'hui dans le
discours c'est que on a une caisse qui
fonctionne parfaitement et on veut la
supprimer pour entrer dans un régime que
l'on sait qu'il n'a pas fonctionné une
manifestation qui fait suite à l'appel
du collectif sos retraite dont les
revendications ne sont pas les mêmes que
celles de l'interprofessionnelle qui a
appelé à un nouveau rassemblement ce
jeudi
en attendant les avocats seront reçus
mardi par le premier ministre edouard
philippe
pour tenter de trouver un compromis sur
le projet de réforme est alors que le
projet de loi arrive à l'assemblée
nationale le débat continue de faire
rage chez l'opposition 71 députés ont
commencé aujourd'hui l'examen en
commission du texte avant son arrivée
devant l'hémicycle vam de mille
amendements ont été déposés dont dix
neuf mille rien que pour la france
insoumise une longue bataille risque
d'avoir lieu à l'assemblée avec de
nombreuses propositions de l'opposition
regarder les principales
[Musique]
oh
tous
[Musique]
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
carbon de 16 avocat au barreau de paris
car bond de 16 bonsoir bonsoir d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france une
manifestation aujourd'hui on lisait
15000 avocats dans les rues de paris
les robes noires étaient en force
aujourd'hui oui oui c'est un projet de
loi qui nous mobilisent parce que il
nous atteint dans l'avenir même de nos
cabinets dans notre indépendance aussi
avec le poids de charge augmentant pour
les cabinets donc si vous voulez oui les
avocats se sont mobilisés ce qu'ils
pouvaient venir était là l'opposition à
cette réforme des retraites et fait
l'unanimité au sein de votre profession
oui oui oui
personne n'est satisfait d'un mécanisme
qui va engendrer une hausse des charges
sur une profession qui en supportent
déjà beaucoup on a vu lors de la
manifestation un squelette revêtue d'une
robe d'avocat se balançant au bout d'une
perche
un symbole fort oui alors qui peut
choquer certains puisque la robe
d'avocat n'a pas vocation à servir de
déguisements ce que ça manifeste c'est
finalement le fait que les avocats sont
désemparés donc ces images peu habituel
pour une profession qui est quand même
plutôt académique d'habitude un convoi
dans les tribunaux donc dans des débats
qui sont généralement feutrée si
aujourd'hui mes confrères manifeste de
façon aussi exubérante diront ce qu'ils
voudront critiqué ce mode de
communication
et bien c'est d'abord la manifestation
de leur détresse justement une détresse
est ce que vous pouvez nous l'expliqué
très concrètement cette réforme des
retraites
si elle passe dans le quotidien d'un
avocat aujourd'hui quel impact alors
l'impact
je vais pas je vais vous épargner les
tranches d'âge a mais ceux qui seront
les plus touchés sont ceux qui vont qui
sont nés après 75 en moyenne pour un
cabinet ça veut dire que on va augmenter
les charges de moitié et les cotisations
de moitié voilà c'est à dire qu'on va
quasiment doubler
votre charge avant même que vous
puissiez commencer à gagner un euro
concrètement qu'est ce que ça veut dire
ça veut dire inquiets des cabinets qui
vont être en péril économique
donc ils vont fermer c'est ça ce que
voulait dire ce squelette vêtu d'une
robe d'avocat ça voulait dire qu'il ya
des cabinets pour lesquels c'est la mort
annoncée
ces cabinets là pour l'ensemble des
citoyens français ça veut dire que ces
cabinets ne viendront plus au secours
des justiciables
qu'est ce que ça veut dire pour les
autres ça veut dire que ayant de plus en
plus de charges
ils auront de moins en moins de temps à
consacrer aux justiciables les plus
démunis parce qu'il faudra bien qu'ils
atteignent un seuil d'amortissement du
cabinet qui va être de plus en plus
important donc les effets de cette
réforme
l'ondé de choc de la réforme si elle
était appliquée telle qu'elle est
actuellement prévu avec toutes les
indécisions notamment en termes d'études
d'impact qui font qu'on peut
difficilement chiffrer aujourd'hui ce
que ça va réellement coûté mais on sait
ce que va être la répercussion sur les
cabinets d'avocats et on sait par
conséquent quelle va être la
répercussion sur l'ensemble des
justiciables français de cette hausse
des charges pour les cabinets d'avocats
c'est à dire moins de disponibilités
moins de temps moins de services car les
avocats rendent beaucoup de services
gratuits d'ores et déjà c'est par
exemple que l'accès à l'aide
juridictionnelle est intégralement payée
par la profession d'avocat ce n'est pas
l'état qui le paye aujourd'hui votre
régime autonome il fonctionne bien et
n'est pas déficitaire
sinon il était on nous avons une réserve
de 2 milliards qui est menacée de
spoliation c'est à dire que c'est
exactement comme si l'état rentrait chez
ceux de vos téléspectateurs qui ont un
plan d'epargne en leur disant eh ben je
ne sais pas gérer donc comme je perds de
l'argent je vais prendre votre argent
donc quand le gouvernement parle de plus
de justice sociale plus d'équité avec
cette réforme des retraites pour vous
c'est pas le cas
nantes a appliqué aux avocats c'est
certainement très loin de l'équité un
savait que si on doit par exemple ça
c'est très facile à saisir si on doit
6000 et le régime des salariés les
professions libérales on oublie une
chose c'est que quand le salarié touche
1 euro il ne paye pas de charges
sociales dessus la profession libérale
paye des charges sociales donc déjà si
vous voulez cette assimilation déjà
mathématiquement est fausse et s'opère
au préjudice des professions libérales
donc des avocats demain une nouvelle
rencontre est prévue entre edouard
philippe et les représentants des
avocats qu'est ce que vous attendez de
cette réunion est ce que vous êtes
confiant
alors écoutez moi je ne suis pas dans
les arcanes du gouvernement dont je ne
sais pas s'il ya matière à être
confiants ou pas ce que je constate
c'est qu'on a aucun signal en l'état
pour être confiant dans ce qui va être
proposé pour l'instant l'état nous a
malmenés nous a négligés
on n'a pas le même pouvoir de nuisance
que les pilotes de ligne ou les
aiguilleurs du ciel
donc pour l'instant l'état s'est mal
comporté avec les avocats
ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
imaginons que l'état soit tenté de
passer en force pour montrer qu'il ne
cède pas et que le gouvernement ait
droit dans ses bottes et que et qu'
edouard philippe pétain candidat tout
désigné pour la droite aux
présidentielles
il lui aurait tort parce qu'il jouerait
à courte vue parce que il peut gagner
politiquement passant en force à
l'assemblée
mais il va perdre avec tous les recours
juridiques qu'on va introduire après et
là l'avis du conseil d'état qui a été
rendu il ya une dizaine de jours et la
lire attentivement justement cet avis du
conseil d'état il légitime également
votre mobilisation mais oui parce que
qu'est ce que dit le conseil d'état il
dit que la loi est imprécise or vous
savez que c'est un motif constitutionnel
pour qu'une loi devienne inapplicable si
elle est illisible incompréhensible
la deuxième chose ils disent que les
études d'impact ce dont nous parlions
tous les deux tout à l'heure c'est à
dire les éléments financiers sont
lacunaires je sais que conseil d'état
mais il faut parler la langue du conseil
d'état quand il dit que c'est lacunaire
ça veut dire qu'il n'a pas ça veut dire
que c'est zéro et enfin il compte les
régimes et il dit il n'y a pas un régime
universel il ya déjà cinq régimes dont
un conte appel universel et à
l'intérieur de ces régimes
il ya une multitude de régimes
dérogatoires
c'est à dire en réalité une multitude
donc
régime puisque ces régimes dérogatoires
sont des régimes différents les uns des
autres
donc il dit qu' en l'état il n'est même
pas capable de compter le nombre de
régimes dérogatoires
parce que comme le gouvernement agit à
courte vue
le texte ne cesse d'évoluer et par
conséquent c'est difficile mais que la
seule certitude c'est car à défaut
d'éléments financiers fiables fourni et
bien on ne peut pas apprécier la
pertinence de la loi et en deuxième lieu
elle est tellement mal rédigé qu'elle en
devient indigente puisque
incompréhensible la bataille de la
réforme est donc lancée depuis
aujourd'hui à l'assemblée nationale est
ce que vous faites confiance aux députés
justement pour défendre vos intérêts
l'intérêt des avocats
non on n'est pas une profession qui est
bien représenté à l'assemblée nationale
c'est à l'honneur de nos confrères qui
sont élus à l'assemblée nationale il
oeuvre dans l'intérêt de leurs
concitoyens pas de leur profession alors
qu'à d'autres professions qui ont des
représentants beaucoup plus
corporatistes non ce que ce en quoi je
fais confiance à l'assemblée nationale
c'est pour ces pour examiner de près les
lacunes notamment financières qui vont
servir à ce que le nouveau régime soit
pérenne et là ils vont soulever des
questions auxquelles le gouvernement
sera bien contraint de répondre
et puis après ça on verra si malgré
l'absence de réponse du gouvernement il
y a des des réflexes suffisamment
panurgique pour faire passer le texte ou
pas en un mot pour conclure vous allez
continuer votre mobilisation
ah oui nous nous sommes déterminés et
elle continuera que personne ne se
trompe pas elle continuera si le texte
devait être voté contre nos intérêts la
lutte continuera après le vote du texte
et je vous garantis que nous gagnerons
devant le conseil constitutionnel
merci beaucoup car bond de 16 d'avoir
accepté notre invitation je rappelle que
vous êtes servis au barreau de paris
donald trump en route vers
l'acquittement le sénat à majorité
républicaine a refusé d'entendre des
témoins supplémentaires et sans surprise
va rejeter les chefs d'accusation qui
prennent les chefs d'accusation qui
pèsent contre le président américain on
fait le point sur cette procédure d'
impeachment avec bath m shelly
c'est un procès très médiatisé qui se
voulait historique et qui au final a
tourné court
mercredi prochain donald trump eux
devrait être acquittée sans grande
surprise par le sénat américain
lancé en septembre dernier par la
chambre des représentants
cette procédure de destitution a très
vite tourné à la course d'obstacles pour
les démocrates
l'espoir de réunir la majorité des deux
tiers des 100 sénateurs requis par la
constitution pour démettre le président
s'est éloigné au fil des jours avec 47
sièges les démocrates ne sont pas
parvenus à obtenir une majorité simple
celle là même qu'il aurait permis
d'obtenir la convocation de témoins
supplémentaires
pourtant durant ces derniers mois
l'espoir semblait revenir dans le camp
des démocrates
grâce notamment aux fuites du livre des
mémoires de john bolton l'ex conseiller
de notre hub qui aurait fait hésiter
quelques sénateurs républicains malgré
le soutien de suzanne collins et de mitt
romney deux sénateurs modérés à la
requête des camps démocrates la chambre
haute a racheté in extremis par
cinquante et une voix contre 49 cette
demande
un coup dur pour l'opposition est un
soulagement pour les proches de donald
trump
c'est une grande tragédie les américains
se souviendront de ce jour où le sénat
s'est détourné de la vérité je suis très
heureux que le sénat ait rejeté la
demande des démocrates d'appeler des
témoins supplémentaires après que la
chambre ait choisi de ne pas le faire
comme je les dis il ne s'agit pas d'une
infraction imprescriptible et les
témoins recherchés par les représentants
de la chambre était à leur disposition
un épisode qui n'a jamais vraiment
inquiété le locataire de la maison
blanche déjà dans les starting blocks
pour la présidentielle de 2000 20 donald
trump prononcera son discours sur l'état
de l'union mardi soir devant le congrès
la veille du jugement qui mettra fin à
ce procès un procès qui semble avoir
renforcé le président et remobiliser son
camp alors que commencent les primaires
de la présidentielle et donc quelques
instants notre débat sur l'ère post ben
brik site qui s'ouvrent et les
négociations entre l'union européenne et
le royaume uni après le divorce quels
accords trouvés est il possible
d'ailleurs d'en trouver un
nous en débattrons avec nos invités
rester avec nous
rt france
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
chaque jour en politique des milliers de
parties d'échecs sont joués mais les
règles ne sont pas toujours respectées
les couleurs changent de camp les pions
prennent la place des rois de films
stratégies peuvent porter des résultats
inattendus
un coup décisif ne fait que repousser la
victoire
les chômeurs et chaque semaine dans
l'échiquier mondial nous analyserons les
coups les plus complexes du jeu
politique internationale
[Musique]
à bientôt sur rt france
[Applaudissements]
c'est le sentiment que vous avez eue
vous aussi ce besoin d'autonomie
oui complètement vrai besoin d'autonomie
besoin de retourner à des choses plus
essentielles en fait est vraiment de
sentir qu'on n'est pas forcément un
poids pour la planète
il ya une idée derrière il ya une
philosophie aussi qu'on a vu la serre
les plantes qui poussent le fait de
vivre avec les plantes comme ça vraiment
commune comme une machine un organisme
et pour fait partie de celles de cet
organisme
on a eu vraiment l'impression de se
construire en même temps quand vous
construisez cette maison en faisant
toutes ces rencontres
je pense que ces gens de projets qui se
fait pas tout seul dans son coin on est
dans un truc vraiment de coopération de
partage de partage
le lac le plus vieux du monde
les lacs n'ont généralement pas plus de
quinze mille ans
baykal à plus de 25 millions d'années
ici vivent des esprits et des divinités
bouddhiste
l'eau pure et transparente du lac aide
les scientifiques à résoudre des
mystères de l'univers
je vois le baïkal comme un ensemble
cohérent je ne savais pas à quoi
m'attendre ici ce n'est pas que je
découvre quelque chose de nouveau ici je
m'imprègne simplement de tout ce qu'il y
a
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce que tu m'as tu 1 est pourquoi
tu m'as tu là qu'est ce que tu m'as tu
as qu'est ce tu m'as ko alors à un vase
il vient pas peur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il est 21h30 heure de paris bienvenue en
direct sur rt france merci à vous qui
nous rejoignent et chats trois jours
après le break site le plus dur reste à
faire dès aujourd'hui le royaume-uni et
bruxelles se lance dans une bataille et
elle s'annonce difficile pour bâtir une
nouvelle relation économique à quoi bon
donc ressembler les nouveaux accords
commerciaux entre les deux éléments de
réponse avec clément hospital
le divorce est actée et c'est désormais
le temps des négociations
l'union européenne et le royaume uni
doivent dès à présent définir les termes
du bric site et boris johnson se montre
ferme pour un accord de libre-échange
nul besoin d'accepter les régulations
européennes
le premier ministre britannique veut
tout de même se montrer rassurant et
s'engage à ne pas faire de concurrence
déloyale a lieu nous ne nous engagerons
pas dans une course effrénée vers le bas
nous ne quittons pas l'union européenne
pour saper les normes européennes
nous ne ferons aucune concurrence
déloyale qu'elles soient commerciales
économiques ou environnementales et
n'écoutez pas seulement ce que nous
disons regardez ce que nous faisons
car de son côté bruxelles la mise en
garde de londres contre toute tentation
de concurrence la présidente de la
commission européenne ursula von der
leyen se dit prête à négocier un
partenariat sans précédent avec le
royaume uni à condition que le pays
respecte les règles durant la période de
négociation qui s'est ouverte au moment
du bric site de notre côté pas de
surprise nous sommes cohérents il y a
des offres pour différents modèles plus
le royaume-uni veulent proches plus
l'accès au marché unique sera facile
mais rien n'est gratuit l'accès à ce
marché unique a une grande valeur
c'est le plus grand marché unique au
monde c'est très important et donc je
pense que c'est simplement une question
d'équité que de respecter les règles un
partenariat essentiel pour les européens
cet accord visera notamment à éviter des
droits de douane et où quotas sur les
biens échangés avec le continent
michel barnier le négociateur en chef de
l'union européenne se dit
si prêt à proposer à londres un accord
commercial très ambitieux du jamais vu
dans l'histoire de l'union comme le
prévoit la déclaration politique
nous devons trouver un équilibre entre
les droits et les obligations
c'est ce qu'a rappelé il ya quelques
instants le seul afin de relayer ainsi
qu'un équilibre par rapport aux accords
que nous avons avec d'autres pays tiers
je pense ici en particulier aux pays qui
ne sont pas membres de l'union
mais qui sont dans l'espace schengen et
qui acceptent la libre circulation des
personnes et qui construire avec nous
depuis des années cet espace unique de
sécurité
les deux parties ont onze mois pour
négocier le commerce la sécurité la
pêche sont les trois sujets prioritaires
sur la table
londres et bruxelles veulent même
s'entendre avant le 1er juillet prochain
sur la pêche
l'un des secteurs où les 27 sont en
position de faiblesse par rapport au
royaume uni les navires européens pêche
aujourd'hui chaque année dans les eaux
britanniques pour une valeur de plus de
700 millions d'euros contre 154 millions
d'euros pour les prises des pêcheurs
britannique dont les européennes
alors après le divorce à les
négociations et on lisa elle s'annonce
après certaines questions sont en effet
susceptibles de ralentir voire de
bloquer les discussions londres et
bruxelles dispose d'une période de
transition de 11 mois et chaque parti a
d'ores et déjà affiché ses objectifs et
défend ses intérêts alors après le
divorce qu'est l'accord trouvé un accord
est il possible c'est l'objet de notre
face à face
[Musique]
et pour en débattre nous sommes en
duplex depuis bruxelles avec dominique
grisé avocat professeur de droit
européen dominique rizet bonsoir en face
de vous gilles casanova consultant en
stratégie et communication alors
messieurs les négociations donc
commencer chacun a affiché ses objectifs
on le disait aujourd'hui qui est en
position fort c'est ce que c'est l'or
aujourd'hui qui est en position de force
selon vous gilles casanova commencer
l'europe est un continent
la dame que nous avons entendu qui parle
comme la chancelière d'un empire
ursula von der leyen vous parlais tout à
fait exprime bien la façon dont d'abord
c'est empire se considère comme l'europe
alors qu'il n'en est qu'une partie et
d'autre part comment il a une faiblesse
intrinsèque qui est qu'il n'est pas
démocratiquement le représentant d'un
peuple qui auraient choisi cette
personne cette dame comme représentante
de l'autre côté nous avons entendu boris
johnson qui lui vient d'être élu dont
des conditions claires transparentes sur
un programme et qui le met en oeuvre et
qui a montré d'ailleurs qu'il ne
cherchait pas à tirer vers le bas
l'europe déjà en faisant que son pays a
le smic le plus élevé d'europe et en
commençant à renationaliser les chemins
de fer ce qui ne va pas du tout dans la
logique de tirer vers le bas le système
par des coûts les plus bas possibles qui
est au contraire ce qui a plutôt été la
tendance de bruxelles donc qui est en
position de force
probablement celui qui peut s'appuyer
sur son peuple parce qu'il l'a élu
plutôt que celles qui s'appuient sur des
institutions qui sont construites pour
tenir à distance des peuples
qui aujourd'hui sont un peu réticent dès
qu'on leur pose une question il répond
non il ya d'ailleurs une réponse on leur
pose plus de questions voilà qui évite
alors dominique griset on vient
d'entendre donc rue gilles casanova a
parlé de l'europe comme un empire qui
repose sur des institutions et qui donc
ne peut pas être plus fort que le
royaume uni avec un ministre élu par son
peuple
votre réaction à ces propos de légines
casanova ma réaction serait plus brahim
plus pragmatique certainement que celle
que je viens d'entendre en fait je pense
que les négociations pour l'après
breakes sites ont déjà commencé depuis
depuis fort longtemps et en tout cas
c'est ce que je m'entends dire par
certains négociateurs sectorielle au
niveau des autorités belges c'est ce que
je connais le mieux bien sûr et donc il
ya des tables de sujets qui ont déjà été
abordées qu'ils font l'objet de
discussions assez avancé la majorité des
sujets d'après ce que l'on me dit ne
pose pas de problème et donc fonds
pourront faire l'objet d'un d'un accord
assez rapidement et puis lé sujet qui
fâche vous en avez parlé mais ces sujets
qui fâchent malheureusement ils ne sont
pas je crois dans un équilibre entre un
premier ministre anglais qui a été comme
un assez curieusement élus suite à
référendum par à propos duquel on peut
quand même se poser quelques questions
je crois est quelqu'un qui n'aurait
aucune légitimité démocratique de
l'autre côté non nous sommes là dans une
discussion qui est avant tout économique
et qui par ailleurs met en place ou en
tout cas mais met en cause un certain
nombre d'autres d'autres éléments alors
je dirais que si on veut commencer par
la négociation économique mais nous
sommes c'est vrai en europe un bloc
assez soudé avec un certain nombre de
libertés auxquelles nous tenons
et d'avancer au point de vue de normes
de qualité de réflexion sur
l'environnement sur la protection des
animaux toutes sortes de choses qui
tiennent malgré tout je dirais d'un
point de vue général à l'essence de ce
que sont les européens malgré tout et
d'un autre côté on a on a quelqu'un qui
effectivement entraîne dans son sillage
un peuple de 60 millions d'habitants
mais qui se trouve entre deux rives
il ne sait pas encore ce qu'on va lui
offrir des côtés de donald trump et il
doit déjà négocié avec l'autre côté de
la manche même si sa préférence va
classiquement pour les anglais du côté
du grand large
il ne sait pas encore à quoi s'en tenir
et donc il est obligé pour l'instant de
renier sa parole
soyons très clairs en étant très très
dur au départ de la négociation mais il
doit le faire parce qu'en réalité il ne
sait pas encore à quelle sauce donald
trump va le manger
gilles gaz annonce que la discussion en
ce qui concerne la question de savoir
qui al'avantage aujourd'hui elle se
place plutôt comme ça et gilles casanova
est ce que vous vous rejoignez les
propos qui vient d'être d'être dit
justement sur le fait que boris johnson
est dans l'incertitude il ne s'est pas
finalement vers qui se tourner sur cette
question des accords commayras d'un seul
instant d'abord le discours selon lequel
l'élection de boris johnson serait
curieux se serait passé dans des
circonstances particulières si l'on veut
chercher sur le continent européen
une élection curieuse qui se serait
passé dans des circonstances
particulières nous pouvons regarder plus
près de nous et nous trouverons très
vite mais
j'ai entendu un discours idéologique
purement idéologique qui nous dit la
négociation sera une négociation
économique puis aussitôt dit les normes
environnementales la protection des
animaux
tout cela c'est pas de l'économie c'est
de la vie c'est la société la question
de qui décide dans un pays ça n'est pas
de l'économie c'est profondément la
raison d'être des civilisations et des
sociétés peser sur son destin et les
nations elles sont le produit de cela et
donc la logique de ceux de cette
discussion c'est la logique d'un pays
d'une nation qui a choisi de reprendre
en main son propre destin
ce qui ne veut pas dire qu'il a le
souhait ce pays de s'opposer au reste de
l'europe
il y a simplement des grands courants
qu'on note dans l'histoire du continent
lorsque la france domine absolument tout
alors l'angleterre s'allie avec
l'allemagne et c'est la défaite de
napoléon à waterloo
sinon lorsque la france est dans la main
de l'allemagne de manière trop violente
occupés ou contrôlée d'une manière ou
d'une autre la grande-bretagne regarde
vers le grand large
on est dans cette situation et dans
cette situation on note que les
dirigeants allemands et leurs amis
français dans des conditions infiniment
moins difficile que la dernière fois ont
de nouveau perdu la bataille
d'angleterre parce que l'esprit d'empyr
qui anime les dirigeants allemands et
leurs amis français se heurte à auffay
peut être parce que c'est une île que
l'idée nationale l'idée de la démocratie
à l'échelle d'une nation qui permet les
coopérations et l'internationalisme qui
entend bien le mot nation à l'intérieur
est quelque chose de plus pertinent
qu'un système qui fonctionne sur un mode
impérial c'est à dire où le sommet n'est
pas désir
et par le peuple parce qu'il n'ya pas un
peuple parce qu'il ya des peuples parce
qu'ils n'ont pas les mêmes débats parce
qu'ils n'ont pas les discussions les
mêmes discussions et qu'on a un système
de prince électeur qui ensuite se
choisissent à un dispositif dans pire il
ya là toute une discussion sur la façon
dont les sociétés humaines peuvent
collectivement faire avancer leur destin
et c'est tout un débat sur la manière
dont le continent européen a avancé
alors les questions qui sont posées
ce sont des questions qui sont je pense
dominique vivement je pense par rapport
à voilà je pense effectivement que ce
que vous avez précisé est assez juste
et il n'y a pas de contradiction chez
moi je pense que les différends les les
européens sont parvenus à se forger
depuis la création de l'europe un
certain nombre de réflexes communs
d'idéologie commune de points sur
lesquels ils parviennent à avancer
ensemble et donc l'économie et ce dont
on discute mais ce qu'ils avancent
avant tout ce sont ces autres idées que
nous partageons en tant qu'européens et
là où je suis particulièrement étonné
par votre discours c'est quand vous
dites que finalement nous sommes
ce serait un progrès de retrouver
aujourd'hui un retour à cet ancien
régime des empires que auquel vous
faites référence est dans le cadre
duquel je suis tout à fait d'accord avec
vous l'angleterre se retourne vers le
grand large voulait réagir les uns
phrase sympathie entre l'allemagne et la
france mais je ne suis pas d'accord je
peux je peux je peux juste je voudrais
juste terminée terminé gilles casanova
région en précisant que c'est oui voilà
tout ce que je veux dire c'est que
justement l'histoire de l'europe des
dernières années a permis de sortir de
cette logique mais bien sûr elle est
plus exigeante cette cette manière de
faire et je crois que on est parvenus
les progrès qui ont été faits montrent
qu'il y avait moyen de ne pas en
retourne et je n'irai pas au moyen âge
mais pratiquement gelé ce que
l'angleterre a fait c'est de faire un
grand pas en arrière
j'ai à nouveau l'esprit dans pire c'est
celui qui domine bruxelles c'est pas du
tout l'esprit britannique
les britanniques veulent le retour du
pouvoir auprès du peuple britannique ce
ça pour lequel ils ont voté en votant
une brique site l'esprit dans pire c'est
un esprit dans lequel le sommet n'est
pas désigné par le peuple et je vous
entends parler des européens les
européens ont avancé les européens et
cetera c'est un discours qui couvre le
champ médiatique ce discours sur les
européens quand on parle sur lèze des
européens il s'agit environ 2000
bureaucrates installé à bruxelles et
leurs mandants qui sont trois ou quatre
fois supérieure installé dans les divers
pays de l'union
il s'agit pas du tout des peuples
l'union interrogés les peuples de
l'union comme des instituts de sondage
le fonds et vous vous rendez compte que
il n'y a pas du tout cette unicité de
vue qu'il y as entre les technocrates
qui sont installés à bruxelles
et ça c'est un élément absolument qui
s'est tenue dans la dignité
mais là on a voté mais qui fonctionne de
manière unifiée parce qu'il s'est mis
d'accord autour d'un certain nombre de
points de vue qui sont des points de vue
politiques très cadrée et qui
considèrent que les populations elles ne
sont là que pour donner leur avis mais
pas pour décider
l'élément le plus clair a été juncker
qui dit aux ou grecs qui viennent de
voter contre un traité et pour élire de
nouveaux dirigeants
les élections servent à exprimer il a
dit aux italiens aussi exprimer le point
de vue d'un peuple mais la politique qui
est menée c'est celle des traités 2000
utilisez vous vouliez réagir aux propos
de gilles casanova alors pas pas ce
dernier point là mais je crois que si on
a avancé justement en europe c'est parce
que de nouvelle génération comme la
mienne on ont passé les frontières ont
regardé quels étaient les cultures des
autres
il n'était plus attachés à leur glèbe et
aux habitudes d'une population locale ce
que vous appelez les peuples je pense
que la grande chance qu'on a aujourd'hui
chez nous c'est justement
l'interculturalité l'ouverture à
d'autres cultures et refermer les choses
en rayon ferment tout ça dans dans une
logique de peuples et de démocratie
locale
je pense que c'est c'est tellement
triste et c'est effectivement un tel
retour en arrière que qui est annoncée
effectivement par cette décision
anglaise qui est dangereuse parce
qu'elle présentait entraîner d'autres
d'autres pays à se retirer de cette
convention qui a été qui a été créée il
ya longtemps maintenant et qui feront
que l'europe se délitera très rapidement
c'est le risque que nous courons à ne
pas prendre le risque de
l'interculturalité c'est à dire de
regarder ailleurs que son propre nombril
le résulat internationalité voilà ce que
je dis mais qu'est ce qu'ils ont plongé
ce qui est intéressant dans ce que vous
dites
c'est que vous dites les choses vous
êtes franc et direct
ce que vous appelez l'europe ce ne sont
pas du tout des centaines de millions de
personnes
mais c'est une petite élite nomades et
plus multiculturaliste qui s'est formé
en tant que élite délibérément nomades
et multiculturaliste et qui a rompu avec
son peuple d'origine qu'elle regarde
avec le même mépris qu'un dirigeant
français de multinationales expliqué sur
une chaîne américaine qu'il venait d'un
petit pays dont personne ne parle la
langue et c'est exactement là le
problème
c'est à dire une oligarchie qui s'est
autonomisée des peuples dont elle
provient et qui prétend les diriger
indépendamment 2 dans l'histoire on a
constaté que ça ça avait du mal à
fonctionner et pour venir sur quelque
chose de plus pragmatique
moi j'ai entendu madame pécresse j'ai
entendu d'autres dirigeants européens
dire il faut faire payer aux
britanniques le prix fort pour le brésil
il faut que ce soit un exemple pour
chacun alors j'ai pensé que c'était
vraiment intelligent de dire ça et de le
faire ce serait encore plus intelligent
parce que si notre premier fournisseur
et l'allemagne notre premier client
c'est le royaume uni donc proposé de
traiter à la dure notre premier client
qui peut aller n'importe quand se
fournir n'importe où ailleurs c'est
vraiment un choix réfléchi et est posée
est raisonnable dominique grise et est
ce que vous partagez cet avis comme quoi
il y aurait bas au fond cette pensée de
faire payer au royaume uni son départ de
l'union européenne selon vous est-ce que
elle existe cette pensée là alors je
suis certain qu'elle existe chez
certaines personnes
mais par contre dans le cadre des
accords commerciaux par exemple
il y à une logique aux actions alors
dans le cadre des accords commerciaux
l'essentiel c'est effectivement de ne
pas créer un pont commerciales entre les
etats-unis et les pays tiers et l'europe
par lequel nous puissions nous faire
assez facilement envahir de produits que
nous ne souhaitons pas par ailleurs voir
rentrer sur notre territoire
communautaire parce que effectivement on
a mis des normes de qualité on a mis
d'énormes même au niveau social même si
elles ne sont si elles sont très loin
d'être parfaite et qu'on n'a pas envie
que ces produits rentrer de manière
indirecte donc effectivement face à
cette incertitude on veut parler au
départ à savoir comment les choses
vont-elles se passait entre les états
unis et l'angleterre
on doit nécessairement être extrêmement
prudent on doit et c'est logique
exiger le respect des normes de qualité
des normes techniques que nous avons mis
en place avec beaucoup de peine mais qui
pour beaucoup de produits permettent que
nous ayons en europe des produits de
meilleure qualité que ce soit dans
l'agricole que ce soit aussi dans la
construction industrielle les jouer
enfin tout ce que vous pouvez imaginer
il ne faut pas que l'angleterre soit un
sas pour que tous les produits de
moindre qualité ayant été construits
avec des normes sociales moins favorable
puisse rentrer en europe et donc dans
cette mesure l'un il est nécessaire qu
on ait une négociation sérieuse et
sévère avec l'angleterre et ce qui s'est
passé avec la nouvelle déclaration du
premier ministre
c'était comme un pied de nez c'est à
dire qu'il dans le cadre des
négociations avant break site
on nous a expliqué que le but n'était
pas de jouer avec les pieds de l'europe
que le but n'était pas de diminuer ces
normes d'ailleurs les normes anglaise
était tout à fait excellentes et que par
conséquent tout ce qu'on veut c'est
avoir le libre accès pour les produits
mais ne pas obéir aux autres normes
mais si on négocie d'ailleurs des
accords de libre échange ou
les qualités la question de la manière
dont les poulets sont traités aux états
unis n'est pas réglé eh bien on a alors
insisté alors il va effectivement
permettre l'entrée en europe de produits
que nous ne souhaitons pas avoir alors
2000 grise être sévère dans la
négociation gilles casanova il nous
reste quelques minutes je vous propose
d'écouter michel barnier il était
présent à bruxelles vous réagir après
juste après michel barnier négociateurs
chef de l'union européenne donc pour le
breake site a déclaré qu'il était prêt à
proposer un accord commercial très
ambitieux sans droits de douane ni de
quotas sur toutes les marchandises vous
nous direz ce que vous en pensez après
on l'écouté
c'est le prêt à proposer un accord
commercial très ambitieux comme pilier
sans preuve de file partenariat sans
droits de douane ni quota sur toutes les
marchandises en transit entre marché
unique de 450 millions de personnes good
grille nous devons maintenant nous
mettre d'accord sur des garanties
spécifiques et efficace pour assurer
l'égalité des chances à long terme cela
signifie un mécanisme permettant de
maintenir les normes élevées dont nous
disposons matière sociale
environnementale climatique fiscale et
dette d'état et dont leurs évolutions
futures taxes and state aid matters tous
des futurs développe alors il vous reste
une minute chacun messieurs pour réagir
aux propos de michel barnier pour
conclure gilles casanova c'est le moment
de comédie et fantaisie on nous dit que
l'angleterre va faire entrer des zones
et marchons 10 terrible qui viennent des
états unis
mais on est en train à bruxelles de
négocier avec les états unis un type 2
traités qui permettra bien pire que ce
que l'angleterre ne fera jamais on nous
parle de normes sociales qui ne sont pas
à la hauteur et l'angleterre pourrait
faire entrer des produits et des normes
sociales qui ne sont pas à la hauteur
mais qu'est ce qu'on fait avec la chine
que font les seize pays de l'union
européenne qui ont négocié avec la chine
et que fait la commission qui m
m'accepte de chine des produits qui ont
des normes sociales sans commune mesure
avec les nôtres c'est une comédie une
comédie pour gilles casanova dominent
égalisait pour conclure alors je pense
pas devoir répliquer à ce qu'il dit et
je pense que c'est assez inexact mais je
dirais que healy a en fait deux choses
différentes
les pour en ce qui concerne les produits
dont je partage entièrement nu la pensée
de monsieur barnier
je dirais qu'en ce qui concerne les
produits qui sont produits en angleterre
je ne pense pas que nous ayons de
grandes difficultés de ce côté-là ça je
n'ai pas dit tout à l'heure je pense
qu'effectivement il y a des règles en
angleterre qui ne seront pas revus à la
baisse
après le mexique
encore une fois notre problème majeur
c'est de ne pas permettre l'entrée
indirecte de produits que nous ne
voulons pas voir chez nous et que
contrairement à ce que dit monsieur
casanova
nous ne sommes pas prêts à laisser
rentrer dans le cadre des grands accords
de libre échange il ya bien sûr des
exceptions et des contrôles et des
contrôles par rapport à nos normes
c'est bien évident merci beaucoup
dominique qui grise est je rappelle que
vous êtes avocat professeur de droit
européen vous des batié ce soir avec
gilles casanova consultant stratégie et
communication merci at elle a tous les
deux voilà c'est la fin de cette édition
restez avec nous sur rt france dans cinq
minutes un nouveau point complet sur
l'actualité a tout de suite
[Musique]
cet accord c'est un accord politique
ça va bien au delà d'une simple guerre
commerciale
il est clair que la chine avec un
beaucoup plus à perdre que les états
unis je suis pas convaincu tout de même
que le jeu ne soit pas nous équilibré
qu'il n'y paraît
vous avez un certain de secteurs
d'activité aux états unis qui ont été
lourdement impactés s'aperçoivent qu'ils
sont en train de perdre leur statut de
superpuissance et unique superpuissance
en la chine est un pays qui peut
beaucoup plus rapidement que n'importe
quel autre pays du monde se passer des
états unis et entraîné avec elle en plus
un certain nombre d'autres pays
européens qu c'est aujourd'hui la chine
qui remet en cause l'hégémonie
américaine
il creuse le sol pour me trouver
lisa native quelqu'un ici sortait
c'est un travail dangereux oui même les
enfants travaillent pour en extraire et
c'est pas mal et ça c'est canal
[Musique]
fraude est votre droit
c'est pourtant leur seul moyen de
surpris
[Musique]
il semble qu'il existe une architecture
naturel reposant sur le pli quel
avantage la nature aux rétais la
pratique et l'origami et comment
peut-elle produire des schémas de pliage
aussi complexe l'évolution a dû revenir
les systèmes de clips heureux parce que
cela permet de développer de très
grandes surfaces à l'intérieur de tout
petits espaces ce n'est donc pas
surprenant de voir de l'origami dans les
ailes d'insectes dans les feuilles dans
l'intestin
on peut même voir des systèmes de pleyel
semblables sur le cortex les objets
inspirés par les origamis surgissent
déjà dans notre quotidien
comment imaginer que le pliage d'une
simple surfaces planes nous porte vers
la découverte d'un code universel de la
nature qu'est ce que tu m'as tu es
pourquoi tu m'as tu là
bien toujours qu'est ce que tu m'as tu
restes humains au alors un vase il vient
pas peur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
france la réforme des retraites continue
a cristallisé les débats les députés ont
commencé à examiner en commission
spéciale le texte de la loi
l'occasion pour le collectif sos
retraite d'appeler à se mobiliser
plusieurs milliers de manifestants
avocat infirmiers kinés ou encore
stewart ont défilé à paris
ils dénoncent l'injustice de ce projet
pour les professions libérales
le divorce entre le royaume uni et
l'union européenne est actée reste
maintenant à définir la nature de
l'accord qui va régir les relations
commerciales entre londres et bruxelles
et chacun entend défendre ses intérêts 1
michel barnier négociateur européen pour
le break site affirme vouloir offrir à
londres un accord commercial très
ambitieux boris johnson lui s'engage à
ne pas faire de concurrence déloyale à
l'union européenne
caucus de l'iowa aujourd'hui une
élection qui marque le coup d'envoi des
primaires démocrates
ils sont onze en lice pour représenter
le parti démocrate à la présidentielle
américaine et 4 semble se détacher dans
les sondages nationaux
parmi eux joe biden et bernie sanders
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez en direct sur rt france une
réforme des retraites qui est loin de
faire l'unanimité au moment où le texte
est examiné à l'assemblée une nouvelle
manifestation a eu lieu à paris ce lundi
le cortège est parti de la place de la
bastille pour rallier la place de
l'opéra est les professions libérales
comme les avocats dénoncent une réforme
qui augmentera leur cotisation le point
avec katia technique
la manifestation du 3 janvier à l'appel
du collectif sos retraites a mobilisé
des milliers d'avocats et de professions
libérales à travers la france ils se
sont tous déplacés
tous les barreaux était représenté il le
conteste cette réforme des retraites qui
les obligera à augmenter les cotisations
par exemple pour les avocats c'est
cotisation passerait de 14 à 28 % alors
que distillent leur caisse fonctionne
parfaitement elle est même excédentaire
je vous propose d'écouter quelques
avocats croisés sur le parcours pour ce
qui concerne l'art au maroc 520 cadre
d'une centaine gagnent moins de 2000
euros par mois
et quand on est doublement des
cotisations passage à 14 à 22 %
un certain nombre de cabinets vont
devoir mourir et les personnels sont
menacés il faut faire comme les avocats
parce que nous on a un système qui
fonctionne donc il faudrait que tout le
monde se met au régime autonome et il y
aurait plus de problème de retraite en
france il ya quand même un grand
paradoxe aujourd'hui dans le discours
c'est que on a une caisse qui fonctionne
parfaitement et on veut la supprimer
pour entrer dans un régime que l'on sait
qu'ils ne va pas fonctionner parce que
le système de la solidarité aujourd'hui
ça ne marche plus les gens n'y croient
plus donc il faut des régimes autonome
voilà il se trouve qu'on a des réserves
qu'on est excédentaire alors peut-être
que c'est ça qui l'intéressent
effectivement on se pose la question
quand même mais ses réserves
on les a constitué avec les cotisations
nos confrères nous servent à alimenter
une - fonds de solidarité entre nous ce
qui fait que ça nous permet d'avoir
quelques oeufs soit l'avocat son
activité avoir une retraite minimum
identique à tous des milliers d'avocats
et de professions libérales comme des
soignants des médecins également des
pilotes les experts comptables et est
aujourd'hui à paris de bastille à opéra
pour se plaindre de cette réforme pour
la contester augmentation des
cotisations je les dis mais également
baisse des pensions à prévoir christiane
féral-schuhl qui est la présidente du
conseil national des barreaux estime que
cette cette réforme et à rejeter dans
son ensemble je vous propose de
l'écouter cette réforme de la retraite
c'était la réforme de trop
mal engagés pas abouti et d'ailleurs
hier au sujet vous savez tous la durée
du congé parental de cinq à douze jours
la ministre a indiqué que mon vote se
justifier parce qu'on savait pas comment
financer les le fait de passer de cinq à
douze jours donc a fortiori on peut
imaginer que la réforme des retraites
qui est la réforme dont on vous dit
qu'elle est la plus importante depuis
son temps eh bien on n'a pas de
garanties sur le financement et nous ça
va mettre en difficulté au moins 50 % de
la profession d'avocat mais ça va mettre
en difficulté l'ensemble des professions
libérales
prenez le cas des infirmiers et des
infirmières j'ai discuté avec des
kinésithérapeutes avec des
ergothérapeutes
alors soit on décide de supprimer ces
métiers mais ce sont des métiers de
proximité
donc cette mobilisation s'est rappelé la
place qu'occupe
ces professions nous sommes 18
profession rassembler et nous aimons
notre métier notre engagement à
l'arrivée à opérant un cortège s'est
détachée notamment les avocats du
barreau de lyon et ils ont tenté une
action ils sont arrivés près de la place
vendôme pourquoi parce que c'est le lieu
du ministère de la justice ils ont
réclamé la démission de nicole belloubet
la garde des sceaux
je rappelle que les 18 professions
concernées aujourd'hui qu'ils étaient
dans cette manifestation sont en grève
glissant depuis le 3 janvier
pour les avocats c'est une date un peu
fatidique puisque demain mardi
ils ont rendez vous avec le premier
ministre edouard philippe pour négocier
encore au sujet cette réforme ou
carrément demandé de la retirer
et le débat continue de faire rage à
l'assemblée nationale chez l'opposition
22 mille abonnements été déposés dont
dix neuf mille rien que par la france
insoumise une longue bataille risque
d'avoir lieu à l'assemblée avec de
nombreuses propositions de l'opposition
regarder les principales
[Musique]
où
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
le nombre d'amendements déposés donc
important néanmoins selon la députée les
républicains constance le grip il y a
beaucoup de doublons et pour sébastien
jumel du parti communiste malgré le
travail que demandent ces vingt-deux
mille amendements déposés tous seront
défendues pour mettre fin à la réforme
je vous propose de les écouter c'est un
cas de figure effectivement inédit
depuis le début de la législature et la
commission parlementaire spéciale une
véritable montagne d'amendements a gravi
alors il se trouve que dans ces quelques
22 mille amendements
tous n'ont pas forcément exactement
le même intérêt il ya beaucoup
d'amendements qui se répètent des
amendements qui se duplique qui sont
rédigées à l'identique bien évidemment
les amendements qui se répètent qu'ils
sont des duplications d'amendements déjà
existants seront certainement examiner
de manière plus rapide 1 les insoumis
les communistes
mais parlementaires de gauche
ont déposé un grand nombre d'amendements
pour s'opposer à vasco mauvais projet et
nous allons les défendre à main et nous
allons porter les alternatives une par
une parce qu'il y a des solutions
alternatives aux mauvais projet qui nous
est proposé le déficit n'existe pas
c'est un leurre l'universalité c'est un
mot volet puisque après cette réforme on
ne traitera pas de la même manière
quelqu'un qui ait eu un métier pénible
une retraite une carrière hachée
quelqu'un qui a eu qui a nagé dans le
luxe calme et la volupté et donc voilà
on va faire notre boulot de
parlementaires faire rentrer dans
l'hémicycle dans la commission ce que
les gens nous disent sur le terrain déjà
plus de 300 démission dans le secteur de
la santé à 19 nouveaux chefs de service
ont donné leur démission aujourd'hui à
paris depuis plus d'une semaine les
médecins mettent la pression sur les
gouvernements en enchaînant les
démissions partout en france une
nouvelle manifestation d'hôpital public
est prévue le 14 février
objectif protester contre la baisse du
budget mais également contre la réforme
des retraites une contestation qui
éclatent dix mois après le début de la
grève des services d'urgence on est
engagé dans un combat qui va être un
combat long mais qu est un combat
primordial parce que cette réforme est
extrêmement dangereuse pour l'ensemble
de nos professions du soin elle est
dangereuse pour les médecins mais elle
est dangereuse pour l'ensemble des
paramédicaux et donc les dangereuses
pour les français parce qu'elle va
entraîner une casse très importante dans
la profession et donc on va se dire on
est en droit de se demander qui va vous
soigner demain pour les paramédicaux
c'est la même problématique que pour les
avocats c'est à dire que leurs
cotisations vont passer de 14 à 28 % et
ce sont des professions qui ont des
tarifs qui sont comme pour les médecins
au plus bas de la moyenne européenne ils
ne pourront pas faire face à ses charges
et donc des centaines et des centaines
de cabinets vont fermer et pour les
médecins ce sont les pensions qui vont
diminuer de 30 à 34 %
donc ça veut dire que un tiers des 2
dudu du bénéfice peine un tiers un tiers
de la manne économique des retraites va
diminuer va diminuer et ça on ne pourra
pas y faire face non plus ça va baisser
l'attractivité de nos professions qui
dit baisse d'attractivité dit que moins
de médecins - s'installer donc plus de
déserts médicaux et sait aussi qu
l'hôpital va très mal aussi que les
urgences vont très mal on sait que la
médecine de ville va très mal fin bref
on se demande s'il ya un endroit dans le
soin qui ne va pas mal suite à la
gestion de l'état et on en vient à la
visite des manuels maquereau en pologne
on le sait il ne partage pas les mêmes
idées que son homologue andré luda à mai
lors d'une conférence de presse il a
salué cet après-midi un tournant dans
les relations avec la pologne au moment
où le royaume uni quitté l'union
européenne
au cours de cette visite de deux jours
il sera aussi question de coopération
militaire ou encore d'énergie nucléaire
et renouvelables et sur le sujet du
climat varsovie et paris et n'ont pas
toujours été d'accord on le rappelle
emmanuel macron s'était agacé du blocage
de la pologne alors réticente à l'idée
d'inscrire à l'agenda européen
l'objectif de neutralité carbone pour
2050 une visite en pologne au cours de
laquelle emmanuel macron a également
évoqué la russie un voisin de l'union
européenne avec qui il est nécessaire de
composer écouter la france n'est ni pro
russe ni anti russe elle est pro
européenne et il se trouve que quand je
regarde une carte et je crois que vous
avez le même sentiment quand vous la
regardez monsieur le président on voit
très clairement que la russie est en
europe même si elle n'est pas dans
l'union européenne et qu'elle est dans
notre voisinage et que nous n'avons
aucun intérêt à avoir une situation qui
consiste à ne pas regarder en face notre
relation avec la russie et l essai d
conflit gelé s'accumuler ou des
malentendus là aussi se poursuivre je
n'ai absolument aucune naïveté mais je
sais que dans l'intérêt de la sécurité
de l'europe de la france comme de la
pologne
nous devons avoir un dialogue politique
exigeant avec la russie et pour claude
blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales les sujets rapprochant
la france et la pologne sont nombreux et
coûteux dans les mains qui est évident
dont on parle pas souvent c'est le
maintien des principes de la politique
agricole commune
c'est une invention française dit on ça
a beaucoup profité à l'agriculture
allemand dans le passé ça a profité à
tous les états membres
et depuis quinze ans ça profite beaucoup
à la pologne un certain nombre d'états
pense que cette politique devrait être
démantelée ou en tout cas que
elle coûte trop cher et il va y avoir en
effet dans les prochaines années une
renégociation des principes de la
politique agricole commune pour la
verdir si j'ose dire la verdir au carré
c'est à dire en faire une politique
écologique
bien sûr il faut qu'elle devienne plus
écologique mais sur ce sujet de la
politique agricole commune je pense
qu'il ya un point commun entre la france
et la pologne
bien sûr il ya aussi le réchauffement
climatique c'est un sujet délicat
difficile puisque la pologne à une
économie où le charbon rejoint un rôle
clé c'est un héritage il faut en tenir
compte il faut ménager les transitions
et il faut en discuter
je crois que les deux présidents ont
parlé aussi de d'un char du futur donc
une coopération dans le domaine
militaire
et puis bien sûr il y à la coopération
triangulaire entre la france la pologne
et l'allemagne et pour des raisons un
petit peu inconnu ce format ne s'est pas
réuni depuis très longtemps et je crois
que les deux présidents ont décidé que
il convenait de ressusciter ce format de
weimar avec la chancelière
le président français et les
responsables polonais après 47 ans de
vie commune bruxelles et londres doivent
désormais définir leurs futures
relations michel barnier a présenté ce
lundi le projet de mandat de la veille
de négociations de la commission
européenne avec le royaume uni pour
déterminer la nouvelle architecture de
leurs relations après le break site
boris johnson s'engage à ce que londres
ne fasse pas de concurrence déloyale à
l'union européenne un partenariat
ambitieux pour leur relation poste
briques site qui porte sur trois
chapitres
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qu'est la pêche est un des secteurs les
plus impactés par les négociations post
break cite le secrétaire d'état chargé
des affaires européennes
ameline montchalin affirmé sur twitter
qu'il n'y aura pas d'accord commercial
sans accès aux eaux britanniques pour
les pêcheurs français
la ministre est attendu demain dans un
port de pêche normand pour rencontrer
les acteurs de la filière et apporté le
soutien du gouvernement aux
professionnels de la pêche et pour
christopher chanterai vice président de
l'association british community
committee aux france le royaume uni doit
revenir sur certains droits perdus après
l'accord du 31 janvier écouter le tout
ce qui concerne les étudiants et le prix
de la scolarité dans les universités
britanniques
les britanniques qui résident dans les
pays en dehors du royaume uni dont les
parents les familles ne souhaitent pas
payer ou tarif étrangers qui est le
double du tarif des fins domestiques
jusqu'à maintenant c'était l'intérêt que
deux domestiques
par ailleurs il ya le problème de la le
droit que du droit qu'on a perdu de
s'établir dans un autre pays membre de
l'union
la une les britanniques qui sont établis
dans les pays de
nous à 27 risque de se voir enfin deux
de ne pas pouvoir progresser
professionnellement
si pour les employés et pour les clients
en ce qui concerne les libéraux c'est
plus difficile de s'établir dans un
autre pays j'ai des collègues qui
partent qu'ils changent de pays tous les
2-3 ans là ce sera beaucoup plus
difficile pour ces gens-là jour j aux
états unis la primaire démocrate à
commencer par le caucus de l'iowa une
élection atypique au cours de laquelle à
main levée seront désignés des délégués
et ce sont eux qui choisiront le
candidat démocrate
une étape incontournable et très
déterminante explications avec françois
teese qui évite chez hgrégoire d'ossès
dans un caucus pas d'isoloir mais des
règles bien spécifiques
les sympathisants se réunissent dans
différentes salles écoles au gymnase de
l'état john dix organisateurs du caucus
pour les démocrates du comté de johnson
explique ce processus particulier nous
avons ici un auditorium divisé en
sections
c'est une belle division naturel ainsi
le président peut mettre bernie si
warren ici boutih gaig là bas vous
pouvez voir de belles cloisons clair les
personnes choisissent en quelque sorte
leur coin brandissent leurs pancartes
et il se dirige vers l'endroit où ils
sont attirés il faut obtenir 15% de la
salle pour pouvoir être éligible
c'est ce qu'on appelle la viabilité les
grands groupes peuvent donc envoyer des
délégués au niveau suivant
puis il ya plusieurs niveaux avant
d'arriver à la convention nationale de
milwaukee mais plus petit groupe doit
faire en second choix et ils peuvent
soit le faire en fonction de leur
deuxième favori soit en fonction du
candidat qu'ils veulent sanctionner le
plus grand suspense règne les quatre
favoris restent relativement proches
dans les sondages bernie sanders en tête
suivi de l'ancien vice président joe
biden
pique boufigue un puits elizabeth warren
une campagne tronquée par le procès en
destitution de donald trump à washington
privant certains candidats siégeant au
sénat de plusieurs meetings ces
dernières semaines
les dernières heures sont cruciales de
nombreux habitants de l'iowa comme
nombreux démocrates hésitent encore
il se peut qu'il soutienne un candidat
plus que les autres et si la dépendance
sondages ils peuvent exprimer cette
préférence les beaucoup d'encore indécis
ils essaient de prendre une décision
finale avant de participer au caucus est
donc la dernière vague de huit îles la
dernière vague de publicité ces
dernières le prospectus pourrait être
celui qui va faire changer d'avis si
cette personne signe que la tension
monte à la proche du vote
un sondage très attendue d'un journal de
référence dans l'iowa n'a pas été publié
comme prévu samedi soir l'équipe de
pique boufigue et ayant soulevé des
doutes sur la façon dont il avait été
mené un vote dans l'iowa qui pourrait
d'ores et déjà s'avérer cruciale pour
les démocrates
depuis bill clinton en 1996 des
vainqueurs des caucus de l'iowa ont
toujours remporté la primaire
et concernant cette primaire démocrate
les derniers sondages sont très serrés
parmi les favoris trois poids lourds du
parti mais aussi de nouveaux visages qui
pourrait être adopté un nouveau souffle
nécessaire à une victoire démocrate face
au candidat républicain donald trump
cécile à chaumont le favori jo byden 77
ans 8 ans auprès de barack obama à la
maison blanche ont assuré une solide
crédibilité à l'ancien vice président
des états unis depuis son entrée en lice
en avril il se maintient en tête des
sondages mais c'est traditionnel gaffe
préoccupe
si je suis le candidat je le battrai
comme un tambour
s'il ne fait pas de bons scores dans
l'iowa et le new hampshire les deux
premiers états à voter il perdra son
statut de favori deuxième grande figure
démocrate le sénateur bernie sanders 78
premier dans les sondages de l'iowa
grâce à des levées de fonds record à
grand soutien des jeunes et malgré une
crise cardiaque à l'automne 2010 9 celui
qui appelle à une révolution politique
pour une société plus juste et ferait
une partie de l'électorat démocrate
premières figures féminines la sénatrice
elizabeth warren 77 ans est classée
troisième dans les sondages nationaux
après avoir été jusqu'à menacer le
favori jo byden dans les intentions de
vote cet ancien républicaine
pourfendeuse de wall street a perdu la
faveur des électeurs pour avoir trop
tergiverser sur la question de la
réforme de la santé est essentielle aux
états unis première surprise de cette
campagne
pique boufigue aigles 38 ans homosexuel
fervent croyant diplômés de
prestigieuses universités mais sans
expérience au niveau national et son
soutien dans le parti ce maire d'une
petite ville du midwest a aussi servi en
afghanistan
chaque fois que mon parti a gagné la
maison blanche au cours des 50 dernières
années c'est avec le candidat qui était
nouveau dans la politique nationale
concentrer sur l'avenir
pas pris dans les voix de washington et
ouvrant la porte à une nouvelle
génération de leadership voilà comment
nous gagnons cinquième dans les sondages
nationaux il est troisième dans l'iowa
s'il était élu il deviendrait le plus
jeune président de l'histoire des états
unis
seconde femme amy klobuchar 59 ans cette
sénatrice du minnesota petite fille d'un
mineur est avec elizabeth warren l'autre
favorite assumé du puissant quotidien
new york times en cinquième position
dans l'iowa
elle ne parvient pas à séduire sur le
plan national le seul candidat d'origine
asiatique encore inconnu il y a un an
l'homme d'affaires andrew yang 45 ans
s'est fait connaître avec une
proposition un revenu universel mensuel
de 1000 $ pour tous les américains
enfin michael bloomberg 77 ans quatrième
dans les sondages au niveau national est
bien connu du public ce milliardaire
ancien maire de new york
ex républicain puis indépendants se
démarque avec une stratégie inédite
faire l'impasse sur les votes des quatre
premiers états il ne se présente qu'à
partir du super tuesday le 3 mars
lorsqu'une quinzaine d'états votre ou
la turquie a bombardé lundi des
positions de l'armée syrienne dans le
nord-ouest du pays faisant au moins
treize soldats pour ankara il s'agit de
représailles à des tirs qui avaient fait
quatre morts côté tueur françois xavier
lambert les bulldozer soulève les
décombres de maisons pour aider à
retrouver des survivants ensevelis
comme plusieurs autres localités la
ville de sarmine dans le nord ouest de
la province d'idlib fait partie des
zones touchées par les combats entre
l'armée turque et les forces de damas
selon ankara les militaires turcs visait
avait été envoyée à delhi pour renforcer
des postes d'observation se trouvant
dans cette région et leur déploiement
avait été annoncée aux armées syriennes
et russes pour le président turc son
pays n'a fait que se défendre face à une
attaque non justifiées tout d'abord
quatre de nos soldats ont été tués par
la tacc perfide menée par le régime
syrien
qu'il repose en paix je présente mes
condoléances à leurs familles à notre
peuple dans la même attaque neuf de nos
soldats ont été blessés dont un
grièvement
les blessés sont soignés dans nos
hôpitaux la turquie comme lors des
attaques précédentes a déjà répondu et
continuera de répondre à toute attaque
des cibles sont déjà déterminés là-bas
et nos moyens sont très variés que ce
soit avec des mortiers ou depuis les
airs avec le f-16
depuis plusieurs semaines les forces de
bachar al assad
appuyée par celle de moscou ont
intensifié leur offensive dans cette
province
face à cette pression accrue ankara qui
soutient certains groupes rebelles
syriens a critiqué la russie pourtant
partenaire de la turquie en syrie
mais moscou affirme tout faire pour
mettre un terme à cette escalade des
tensions
premièrement les militaires russes et
turcs sont en contact permanent
deuxièmement il n'y a pas eu de
conversation de haut niveau pour le
moment mais il ne fait aucun doute que
si cela est jugé nécessaire
elles pourraient être organisées dans
les plus brefs délais
troisièmement le ministère russe de la
défense a déjà donné des précisions sur
la situation en libye
quatrièmement nous restons préoccupés
par l'activité continue des groupes
terroristes dans cette région syrienne
signe de la gravité de la situation le
ministre turc de la défense s'est rendu
à la frontière syrienne avec plusieurs
officiers selon les médias turcs ankara
où est égal
ont déployé des renforts militaires en
syrie et dans le reste de l'actualité
internationale en bref et en images
atterrissage d'urgence ce soir pour un
avion d'air canada suit un problème de
moteur l'avion et ses 128 passagers ont
dû faire demi-tour pour la capi par la
capitale espagnole l'appareil faisait la
liaison madrid toronto il avait décollé
en début d'après-midi un des dix noeuds
de l'appareil avait également éclaté au
décollage en grèce plus de 2000 migrants
dénoncé une nouvelle loi durcissant les
procédures d'asile en grèce en marchant
du camp de moria vers le port de
mytilène à sur l'île de lesbos la police
a fait usage de gaz lacrymogènes à des
blessés sont à déplorer
la chine accuse les etats-unis de
vouloir semer la panique
washington a en effet interdit l'entrée
sur le territoire américain de tout non
résidents venant de chine et recommande
de ne pas se rendre dans ce pays
pékin de son côté annonce avoir besoin
urgemment de masques de protection
on le rappelle l'épidémie a fait jusqu'à
présent au moins 360 morts c'est la fin
de cette édition merci de l'avoir suivi
prochain rendez-vous avec l'actualité ce
sera demain à 7 heures heure de paris
excellente soirée sur elle
le foot us qu est ce que c est ce que
c'est du sport est ce que c'est de la
politique
est-ce que c'est du business pense que
vous auriez même peut-être pu ajouter
est ce qu'il s'agit de religion